so
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone good morning at least uh
to those of you on the east coast of
america
it is quite unusual for us to gather
at this early hour um i'm used to
speaking publicly at this early hour so
i'll do my best of course we're doing it
at this time
because of the guests that we're going
to be speaking to in just a little while
sir roger penrose who is
in oxford i think is in oxford certainly
is in the uk
and to accommodate the time there we are
starting on our
end a little bit early relative to what
we normally do
but i guess for some of you out there
this is a really good time
those who join us from the other side of
the world in fact
if you don't mind those of you who are
willing just in the
discussion if you can just say where you
are watching from i always like to see
the variety of different places that
were able to reach
with these conversations so i saw a few
earlier
from various parts in the world india
argentina germany spain
miami that's an exotic one wow that's
scrolling by too fast for me to read but
uh
chicago rhode island yeah a bunch of
india switzerland
amsterdam pakistan melbourne i guess i
didn't really pronounce that correctly
melbourne melbourne they always get on
my case in australia
when i pronounce that incorrectly but
anyway thanks for joining us
and we're going to be speaking to roger
penrose i don't know in about
um 20 25 minutes or so what i'll start
with first is
little discussion of maybe a little
preamble to what
roger and i will talk about and maybe
take a few of your questions
before we get into the conversation as
you no
doubt know roger penrose is one of the
great minds in mathematical physics or
physics or mathematics he has made
impact in
both of those arenas as well as a
crossover
between the two i don't even think he
remembers the fact
there's no reason why he should remember
the fact that
you know i went to oxford as a graduate
student and
i went there because i wanted to study
with roger penrose
and on the first day there i showed up
in his office
and we had a little chit chat kind of
thing and
he told me what he was working on and at
that time
it was so to my ears so
mathematical that it felt to me that it
was
too far away from physics for it to be
something that i
wanted to work on and i was pretty
upfront about that and he suggested that
i
move over to talk about
or work on i should say physics in the
physics department is right across the
street from the mathematical sciences
institute
at oxford so i was only his student for
about two weeks
then i moved over to be a student of
particle physicist graeme ross i also
spent a little time
initially working with the
astrophysicist james
binney so it all worked out well for me
but the irony is
the irony of it is when i
went over to work on physics ostensibly
i got into
string theories many of you no doubt no
and in that
work on string theory i had to make use
of
and learn and master and apply some of
the very mathematical techniques
that roger penrose was describing to me
in our first meeting so although i left
working with him to do things that were
less mathematical i wound up
doing things that were equally
mathematical
just a couple hundred yards across the
street as
as things turn out but again i don't
even think he remembers that that brief
meetings that's all it really amounted
to
but what we'll talk about with roger of
course
is the work that
resulted in his being
anointed if that's the right word here
he is a knight that's really where the
word
anointed should be used but his in the
announcement from the
nobel prize committee that roger won the
2020
nobel prize in physics he shared it and
you may recall that we had a
conversation with andre
guess one of the two individuals that he
shared the prize with which is fantastic
that work of course is in the arena of
black holes it's the mathematical side
of black hole so we'll get into that
conversation but the other thing to
really bear in mind is
roger is a thinker whose ideas
span a whole range
of different subjects he's not one of
those scientists who just
drills down further and further further
in one particular
area as some of you
i'm sure know he has ideas about
cosmology we'll get into those
a little bit he has ideas about the
arrow of time
he has ideas about mind and the
relationship between mind and computers
can the mind really be thought of as a
biological computer many people use that
analogy some people take that analogy
really quite seriously roger has
arguments
based on girdles incompleteness
ideas incompleteness theorem where he
tries to argue and to many people
he has successfully argued i'm on the
fence on this maybe he'll convince me
today if we get into it
that the mind really cannot be
likened to a standard
computer because he believes that the
mind is able to
access certain kinds of understanding
that stands outside of the algorithmic
step-by-step
methodology that's intrinsic to
computation as we usually talk about it
so for him the mind is something that
certainly transcends that
metaphor it really cannot be likened to
a computer and he has ideas about where
consciousness arises and it has to do
with some issues in quantum mechanics
that we will also hopefully have a
little bit of time to talk about
issues in quantum mechanics we have
discussed in these sessions
from time to time the gap in our
understanding of quantum mechanics not
everybody believes that there is a gap i
am one of those physicists who certainly
does believe that there
is a significant gap this quantum
measurement problem this if you will
second step that has to be employed
when using the framework of
quantum physics in quantum physics we
use the basic equation
that er that schrodinger gave us some
time ago
but you take that equation and that's
not enough you then have to take that
equation
i don't know if you're seeing that
equation but i see the equation right
now
but uh you take that equation and then
you have to augment it with the second
step
the second step in which you go from the
fuzzy nebulous
probabilistic description that this
schrodinger equation provides you and
you have to extract a single definite
reality from
that haze of possibilities
for which you have probabilities how do
you do that
and this is a question that many people
have worked on there are
solutions that people have proposed i
would say it's fair
to describe the situation as still
unsettled
and roger penrose has taken that
unsettled quality of quantum mechanics
and within there he argues
we may find the answers
that we've been searching for for
consciousness
i'm skeptical i have to say i'm highly
skeptical
many others are too but it just gives
you the sense
of the boldness of thinking that pemrose
has brought to bear on things
that sparked his imagination
which is a a rare and wonderful
quality and so we'll get into that as we
as we head onward let me just spend a
couple minutes
just giving a little bit of background
on some of the ideas of
black holes so that this conversation
just has a
a little bit of a framing because we may
not start from the beginning
i'm not sure where we're going to go in
the conversation but
many of you know back in november of
1915 albert einstein
was putting the finishing touches on his
general theory of relativity
and he wrote down the final equations of
the general theory
in a paper that got published in 1916
but was at the prussian academy
in november of 1915 that
he wrote down the equations and this was
a monumental moment in the history of
scientific ideas
gravity the most pervasive and obvious
force in the cosmos
was brought within a strong
mathematical description one that went
beyond newton's description which had
various puzzles and problems having to
do with the speed with which gravity
would be
communicated from place to place and so
einstein writes up this paper
and just about a year later
a german mathematician physicist
named carl schwarzschild it turned out
he was at the russian front during world
war one it's kind of an amazing story
he somehow gets a hold of this paper and
starts to calculate with it and he comes
up with a solution
the first exact solution to einstein's
equations
again i'm not exactly sure what you guys
see but i i see that equation in front
of me right now
popped up on the screen which is a
wonderful that's the
so-called schwarzschild metric and
that equation describes the
gravitational
field around a spherical object
and in that equation it becomes clear if
you just
squint at it that something unusual
happens
when the size of the
object the spherical object gets
sufficiently small in fact you can see
it in the equation when r equals
2g m newton's constant the mass of the
object
multiplied by 2 when its size becomes
equal to that number which is known as a
schwarzschild radius
something strange happens you get a zero
in one term
on the second term you get something
that looks infinite so something strange
is happening and indeed the
interpretation of that is that
you're getting what's known as an event
horizon
you're getting a point of no return
if you cross that distance if the object
is sufficiently small
if it's within its own schwarzschild
radius
which is just a number take its mass
multiply by two multiplied by g
if the radius of the spherical object is
small enough
if you crush it down small enough then
the warp in space is so significant
that you can't get away and by you
i mean anything and as we
love to emphasize that also includes
light
and if light can't escape from an object
then
that object is black and ultimately this
is what's known as
a black hole so
you know it's also interesting to note i
don't think we get into it with roger
but
you should sort of bear in mind as well
this possibility of black holes not
using that language but
dark or frozen stars it actually emerged
long before einstein's general theory of
relativity just to give you the full
intellectual landscape here the history
of these ideas way back in the 1700s
there was an english
physicist i think his first name is last
name is mitchell i think it's john
mitchell i hope i'm not saying that you
can correct me if i'm wrong someone can
look it up and wikipedia right now i
think it was john mitchell
he asked a very simple question which is
okay on the surface of the earth there's
a certain escape velocity
i don't know what it is 11 kilometers
per second or something but whatever
there's an escape velocity where if you
throw an object up faster than that
speed
it will escape the gravitational pull of
the earth
but then he noted hey even in newton's
theory
if you made the mass of the earth bigger
then the escape velocity would
be up be higher not be up it would be
larger number
the bigger the earth the bigger the
source of gravity
the faster the object has to leave the
surface to be able to escape the
gravitational pull and just go off into
space
and he said what if you keep on doing
that make the mass of the object
bigger and bigger and bigger make the
escape velocity larger and larger larger
at some point the escape velocity
will exceed the speed of light
if the escape velocity exceeds the speed
of light then light can't escape
the object goes dark so this idea of a
dark
object because gravity is so powerful
the light can't escape
really does not originate with this
short child solution does not originate
in einstein's theory but it's einstein's
theory that supplants
newton's description of gravity so the
fact that there are
these dark objects at least in principle
according to the mathematics
in einstein's theory means that you got
to kind of
take them seriously you got to really
think about them and
einstein when he encountered this result
i don't know if it had anything to do
with the fact that schwarzschild had
beaten him to the punch schwarzschild
gets the first solution of einstein's
equation einstein took his own equations
and he can only solve them approximately
so schwarzschild gets his exact solution
when einstein sees it
he is completely skeptical not of the
situation where the
object is larger than its own
schwarzschild radius you know a star of
the earth whatever
but he's very skeptical that there would
ever be an object
that would be small enough that its
physical
radius would be within its own short
styled radius short child number
and so he's basically saying that these
dark objects do not exist they're in the
mathematics but they don't exist
and to make the rest of the beautiful
long story short we now of course
believe that they do exist in the nobel
prize
this year is for the theoretical ideas
that roger penrose developed
to substantially bolster the
mathematical
case for the existence of these
objects as well as the observational
case that came from
the observational teams that studied the
black hole
that we now call a black hole at the
center of the milky way galaxy it's
interesting as i said that i
pause for a moment because
i suspect that roger penrose
might not describe his own work as
establishing theoretically the existence
of black holes per se we'll get into it
a little bit but
you know what what he really showed as
we'll talk about in a few minutes
is that singularities places where
the mathematics in some sense of general
relativity breaks down places where
you can't extend the trajectory of a
light beam
any further in some sense places where
space unexpectedly comes to an end
it's really time coming to an end to be
a little more precise
that's what his mathematics and his
singularity theorems establish now of
course
black holes are an example of that we
have a
an event horizon this edge surrounding
this
singularity but his insights really have
to do with the singularity
not so much with the existence of the
horizon
so i wonder how there's a little
subtlety there and
we'll talk about how the community
responded to the theorems that he proved
in the 1960s
which showed that this kind of singular
structure
deep inside for example a black hole was
an
inevitable consequence of certain
conditions
within the general theory of relativity
so it's a beautiful story again goes all
the way back to the 1700s
and i'd like to think that that story in
some sense can be thought of as
i mean it's a dominant specific
collection of ideas that we'll talk
about but it's also the case
that in a sense what
roger has spent a lot of his life's work
on
is thinking about things that are
impossible or thought to be
impossible from one way or another
what i mean by that well we'll talk
about how
roger studied and no need to show any of
these things uh to the audience that
we'll talk about when roger joins him
but he
he constructed various shapes that
are impossible to build in the real
world but
on paper you can draw them in a way that
is both convincing
and perplexing shapes as it turned out
that inspired escher in some of his
drawings
roger has been focusing upon
the problems within quantum mechanics
again
issues that some people think or solve
some people think
can't be solved he's been talking about
issues in cosmology
what happened at the big bang was it
really the beginning
of it all so these are the most
perplexing
questions the kinds of questions that
some people say are insoluble
impossible to solve
but raj is all about trying to find
the unexpected solution the creative
solution
to things that otherwise people would
suspect
would remain puzzling forever
all right let me take a question or two
before we bring um
roger into the conversation just so that
we keep this
a little bit interactive uh
escape velocity someone confirms 11.19
kilometers per second so i was pretty
close and i don't know if anyone
confirmed the
first name of mitchell i think it's john
as i said but who knows
um sam banner one question i'll get to
before we bring roger m
when a particle of a particle
anti-particle per that's entangled
when it falls into a black hole what
happens there
that's a good question uh i wish we had
three hours with roger i don't know how
much time he's willing to give us i
think we probably have to wrap it up
in about an hour or so but
that's a deep question sam and it's
really at the forefront
of research today last few years people
have been deeply
perplexed and and coming up with all
sorts of creative ideas
for what entanglement between
particles means when one has fallen over
the edge of a black hole
does the edge of a black hole in some
sense snap
the entangled quality of those particles
according to einstein's ideas that
would not happen because as we'll talk
about with roger the edge of a black
hole
is not some special location in space
from the standpoint of physically
measurable qualities at that location
there's no sign post there's no
obvious marker that lets you know that
you're
at the horizon of a black hole
so classical ideas would suggest that
that's not the case the entanglement
should persist right across the horizon
however when you think about that deeply
together with what's known as the
information
paradox with black holes as we'll talk
about stephen hawking shows
1974 that black holes can radiate if
things can get out of a black hole
the question is do they show an imprint
of the things that fell into a black
hole
and in order for information not to be
lost
they had better show an imprint but that
imprint
through a circuitous chain of reasoning
that i won't try to recount
right now suggests strongly
that the entanglement across the horizon
of a black hole
needs to be rethought there's tension
between
the information being imprinted on the
outgoing radiation from
the hawking process with the persistence
of entanglement across the horizon those
ideas are in tension
due to something called the monogamy of
entanglement
yeah physicists do come up with uh
strange names of things but it turns out
you
can't have entangled particles that are
in
mutually entangled pairs at least if
it's maximally entangled this can't be
maximally entangled with this
and that particle be maximally entangled
with something else further out but that
ladder entanglement had better be there
if
information is to be imprinted on the
outgoing radiation okay there
there's the argument i said i wouldn't
recount it but i just did
so something's got to give because
everything can't be entangled in that
manner
and some have suggested that maybe the
entanglement across the horizon of a
black hole gets snapped
and if it snaps that can yield energy
and if you then look at the entire event
horizon of a black hole
if you have these snapping processes all
over that surface that surface
will have a lot of energy now it's a
real thing
in fact people have given it the name
firewall
a hot surface that would incinerate
anything that approaches it so the whole
idea of falling into a black hole
is a subtle one when these quantum ideas
come
into the story so yeah sam that's a
great question
one that as yet does not have a full
answer but i should say maybe we'll talk
about this in a subsequent
discussion there's been a lot of
progress of late
i'm talking even in the last few weeks
few months
in making mathematical sense of these
ideas and i would say that there's
growing consensus
that the puzzles that
people encountered in the one that i
just described
uh are nearing their conclusion that
people are getting more and more
comfortable that there are
ways of thinking about these things
which don't have any
internal inconsistencies and
allow for information to not be lost
as it falls across a black hole i don't
believe roger agrees with that statement
maybe we'll have a moment or two to talk
about that as
well in one of the approaches
that he has been developing he makes use
of the
possibility that information is lost
inside of a black hole
many of us from the string theory
community and
uh the gravitational community that is
informed by some of the ideas of string
theory
do not think that's the case that we
believe that information is preserved
but uh again not not a done deal
and it's it will be interesting to hear
roger's views now the other thing i
should say
roger's not a great fan of string theory
as many of you know
in fact he wrote a book and i don't
remember the exact
title of the book but i i do know that
one of the words in the title was
fantasy and i think fantasy was uh
his description of string theory so
maybe we'll get into that
a little bit again i don't i'm not
defensive about these kinds of things
as you all know i just find it deeply
interesting
to uh hear a variety of different
perspectives
all right so i think roger's going to
join us in just a few minutes
assuming that uh time in the
uk is still in sync with our time
here and if you have questions
feel free to jot them in the chat i'll
try to look sometimes it's hard
during a live conversation for me to
switch my attention over to grab
questions i do have someone who's going
to try to pull out
some questions on a separate sheet so
i just see a few of you have already uh
asked some relevant questions but
um yeah like darshan doesn't penrose
often criticize string theory
darshana um bulkar yeah
and um uh we'll see
we'll see what uh what roger's feeling
on
those ideas is today and um
i doubt his perspective has changed on
it but it's
it's interesting to hear in more detail
what it is about string theory that
strikes him
as wrong-headed or going in the wrong
direction or
perhaps even the word fantasy so we'll
see
how that looks going forward uh terence
lau
do you think there's matter that exists
inside of a black hole that's a good
question too terence the inside of a
black hole
is a curious place as i was mentioning
you know there are some who suggest that
there might not even be an
interior to a black hole that's one idea
that people have floated but in the more
traditional approach
matter crosses over the edge of the
horizon of a black hole the matter
doesn't disappear
it just is in a different location and
so as that matter is pulled
closer and closer toward the center the
singularity of the black hole
it still exists of course it's within
the event horizon of the black hole the
deep question is what happens when it
hits the singularity
does it still exist is it somehow
flushed out
of our universe is it thrust into a
different universe
we can't really answer these questions
because of this
singularity the singularity that roger
penrose proved is there
and and the curious thing the curious
thing we'll talk about with roger as
well is that
you know singularities it's hard to uh
it's hard to really understand what they
mean
because they are in essence a diagnostic
tool that shows us that our mathematics
breaks down if our mathematics is
breaking down
it's breaking down so it's not as though
the singularity is a thing
it's not like a marble it's not like a
diamond or a jewel
it is a diagnostic which basically
is nature or the mathematical
description of nature
telling us that things are not working
all right so let me now with that
preamble
give a brief introduction to sir roger
penrose roger penrose
is the emeritus rusball professor
of mathematics at the university of
oxford emeritus fellow of
wadham college at oxford
as you know and as we discussed he was
recently
announced to be a recipient of the 2020
nobel prize in physics he's previously
won
a great many awards so many that it
would take half our session
to describe them many of you know roger
from his wonderful books for a general
audiences
emperor's new mind was the first book
wonderful book that i remember reading
in the 1980s
very impactful book for me uh the road
to reality
this deep and uh
expansive tome on the mathematical
approach to describe in the world back
in 2004
and uh his work on black holes black
hole singularities in the 1960s
is uh what we'll talk about here today
is that's what
he has been awarded the nobel prize for
so with that let me bring
roger penrose into the conversation
hi roger how are you hello i'm i'm fine
thanks
it's very good to see you i was just
trying to think the last time that
we crossed path i think it was at a at a
discussion of cosmology
at princeton do you remember that it was
uh you remember that occasion yes
yes right i think it's maybe 2015 2016.
i mentioned to the audience you probably
do not
i would be shocked if you did remember
do you know that i was your student at
oxford for about two days
do you remember that i knew i knew you
were yes i
i don't know whether i remember you
specifically then but
yeah we only met once yeah we met once
and you described to me some of the work
you were doing
yes yes yeah and it was um on the sort
of more mathematical i was describing to
the audience how it's
somewhat ironic that i switched over to
physics because i wanted to do less
mathematical things
and then i wound up doing string theory
and algebraic geometry and
compactification just a couple hundred
yards across the road
over at the physics building so go
figure that's how the world works
in any event deep congratulations
on winning the nobel prize um
well thank you very much yeah it's a
must be have been a
thrilling moment uh to be recognized in
that way
and i'd like to talk about some of the
work
on singularities black holes perhaps we
can even get into some of your other
ideas in cosmology
maybe a little bit on quantum mechanics
and consciousness if
time permits but can we start it's
always nice for our audience to just
hear a little bit
about your own background if you don't
mind i was i was reading
an interview and it was it was
interesting to me to hear you note and
again
perhaps the interview got it wrong so
correct me if i'm wrong
that when you were young you were really
good at mathematics
but you weren't the fastest kid you
needed to be given extra time to
actually
do as well as you could is that is that
accurate i was always very slow yes yes
i could do it but i was slow no i had
this was actually in canada
during the war years and i think i was
in
i forget exactly which grade it was but
we i i hadn't done particularly well in
maths
and i had a teacher who i regarded as
very insightful he was mr
net and he realized i got you know
fairly low marks but i think he realized
also
that uh i i got low marks because i only
got about halfway through the paper
so he decided that he would let me have
um the end of the period which i
after that there was a play period i
think and he said well look you can keep
on going right the way through the next
period
and occasionally i needed even a bit of
the next period after that
but then i used to do pretty well i used
to get in the 90s and
you know he he recognized i was just
slow not stupid
although i did i did get moved down to
class
um yes in my first year when i was in
canada
i was in a combination of high grade two
and low grade three i was in low grade
three
and my teacher there decided i was too
stupid being
in low grade three and she moved me down
into high grade two
um but then uh she couldn't quite fit me
in the crack between those two so
eventually she moved
me up into high grade three which was
better it's better because i couldn't
start
sure she couldn't stand me i think was
the main thing i don't know what it was
i was just too slow that's so
interesting you know it's funny because
when i give final exams
in my classes at columbia i don't
make them time i tell the kids you come
in and we set it up in such a way that
they can sit
and some have stayed as long as 12 or 14
hours
we will start we'll start at three
o'clock in the afternoon and i
i have a ta and sometimes someone leaves
at five or six in the morning
because my view is very similar i don't
care how long it takes
i just want to see whether you can get
it done um
no i think that that was certainly right
i mean i did speed up a bit afterwards
and i managed to
finish finished papers but uh
and so when you were when you were young
were you were you doing
mathematical problems were you uh
tinkering with
puzzles and was that the kind of yeah
my father was well he was a scientist
but he worked in human genetics
but he he was really interested in
mathematics also i had an older brother
who was very
he was different from me he was very
precocious and which
way ahead but he also was interested in
mathematics and physics
i learned a lot of physics from him but
for my father
a lot of mathematics and we used to make
polyhedra and
various things like that and we had a
great interest in that i think it was i
remember one occasion when i noticed
there was a pattern on one of the
uh floor i think whether it's a floor or
a sink surface i can't remember
but it was a tessellation of regular
hexagons all over you see
yeah i looked at this pattern and i
asked my father well look suppose this
thing extended way way over around and
could it go all the way around the earth
and make a sphere you see
so he said no you couldn't do that but
you could do it with pentagons
so he taught me about a dodecahedron you
see so
there's a of course that came back again
with the
non-periodic yeah so that it was at the
origin if you're thinking about the
what's now known as penrose tiles um
i think more the origin was something
else that i got from my father which was
actually he had a book
uh due to the famous uh
physicist mathematician kepler
johannes kepler and in this book there
was a picture
with all sorts of non-crystallographic
designs i mean they were see how far you
can get with with
octagons and things like that and mixed
up with
hexagons and things like that little
patterns with combinations of these and
the biggest one
had a lot of pentagons and i had seen
that before
although i wasn't thinking about it when
i was
finding out about these non-periodic
pentagonal
patterns but then later on well there
were two two
amazing things about that picture one of
them was that
i was i think it was shortly after quasi
crystals and people were
seeing the five-fold tenfold and the
eightfolds
and i went to switzerland and visited
there and i was talking to a
chap called nissan and he had claimed
that there were 12-fold ones
nobody believed him at the time and then
he showed me the
diffraction patterns and i looked at the
diffraction patterns with a
um 12-fold a little dodecagon and then
little
squares and pentagons and things all the
way around and i thought
i i sort of arranged the dots you see
these
you get bright spots on the bragg peaks
and
in the diffraction pattern and i noticed
they made little shapes like pentagons
and squares and things i joined
hexagons and squares and things i joined
them up and i made this pattern around
the
unsightly going inwards from the dodec
again and i looked at this thing
and i said i'm sure i've seen that
picture before
where have i seen that and i realized it
was in the kepler picture and it was one
of the one called ff i think it is
just right over at the side and it was
exactly the same person
but the other thing was the biggest one
with the pentagons
later on i think i was giving a talk
again bringing in the kepler
and i wondered whether this pattern of
pentagons would fit into my
my own patterns and i found a place
where exactly the same lines including
some little lines he put in inside one
of the dodeca
he had decagons decagons and
pentagons things like that you couldn't
quite tell where it was all going
but i took this and i managed to match
it with one of them
exactly in the middle of one of my
pentagon patterns so he more or less had
it before
wow much closer than the islamic people
and people often said maybe in exa
islamic tilings you might see these
things but they have interesting
peasants with pentagons and things but
never never one of these things but
the captain did remarkable very
remarkable yeah
now there's also i i was reading that
you
were inspired by a
impromptu trip to the van gogh museum
what was that about that that was an
escher exhibit is that right that was
at the um there was an international
congress of mathematicians they had
those every four years
i think i was in my second year as a
graduate student in cambridge
and uh somebody told me
i guess i learned about the
international congress which was in
amsterdam in the netherlands
and so i went to it with a friend and
then i remember seeing one of my
lecturers there this was sean wiley who
taught me about algebraic topology and
he had his hand a catalog
and it had this escher picture with the
the night and day with the birds
in the night on one way and the white
birds in the dark and the
dark birds and the white and then sort
of meshed together in the middle
and i thought that was extraordinary and
he said well you go to the
in the vanguard museum there is an
exhibition
by this artist m.c escher i'd never
heard of it before
or him before so i went there and i was
absolutely
stunned by the amazing things there
particularly the one called relativity
with people going upstairs and
do you know the picture with a i i think
i do know that one and
now didn't you and your dad start to
draw well we see i i came away from that
exhibition i think it was in the
vacation period afterwards and i thought
i would like to draw something that i
hadn't quite
seen in the exhibition and i
put pictures with roads and bridges and
rivers going off in possible ways
and i whittled it down simplified it to
this thing people now call the tri bar
this is the impossible triangle thing is
that right and i showed my father
you know and he showed it to all his
friends it made more made them feel a
little ill
my father decided to uh
draw a building yeah that's it yes he
drew buildings um
impossible buildings and then he came up
with the staircase
and so we decided we'd write that's it
we'd write a paper about this
which we did but we couldn't decide
which
journal to send it to because we didn't
know what the subject was we had no idea
what the subject was
so my father said well i happen to know
the editor of the british journal of
psychology
so perhaps we'll set psychology and send
it to them right
so this is a staircase in which you
continue to walk
upstairs and yet you still find yourself
at your starting point as you go around
yes so so anyway we published this and
then
we we credited escher in in the
in the uh acknowledgements and sent a
copy to usher
i mean for asha's uh the museum
yeah i think we're the catalog in the
museum and in the meantime ash had
produced belvedere which was a picture
with a similar
kind of impossibility is that the one
with the waterfall uh
no he did the belvedere is a sort of
building with
with uh it's got pillars which are
joined up in the impossible way
got it got it okay and uh and then he
my father sent a copy of this paper to
to asher
and he got a copy and he then had a
correspondence from my father quite a
bit
and um uh the the staircase was the
first one he did
based on the this is called ascending
and descending right
the waterfall he did a little bit later
got it
amazing so let's turn into um
to the uh initial work that you began to
do thinking about
relativity and ultimately what turns
into
black holes so you know between 1915
when einstein wrote down the equations
and say
you know mid 1950s and so forth
general relativity was no longer
the exciting arena of physics most
people were focusing on quantum
mechanics and
nuclear physics atomic physics things of
that sort
so when you started to think about
einstein's ideas
were you kind of off in a quiet area
of research at that point i wouldn't say
quite that there was quite a bit of
activity but
in britain it was almost entirely in
mathematics departments i think or
entirely as far as i know people were
you know playing around solving the
equations in clever ways and
that's what they were doing um
i got interested i guess let's see
i should it was in 1958
when i was back in cambridge as a
research fellow i was doing pure
mathematics
when i was a graduate student algebraic
geometry and things like that but but i
learned a lot about tenses and how you'd
how useful it was to draw little
pictures with arms and legs which joined
up together rather than indices
and uh i've never seen those pictures
you haven't seen them
i don't know if i have uh i'm not sure i
can
illustrate i guess i could it looks like
you have a whiteboard behind you there
i don't know if it'll show up on the
camera yes
i could use that but um but i guess i
can imagine you're basically tying
together the indices from
different tensors as opposed to just
having repeated uh letters
and they just join them with lines
that's right yeah yeah there is a
picture in carlo rovelli's book i just
if you can find that
i'd have to find the right page yeah
okay good enough
but anyway um yeah you just instead of
seeing an index here in an index here
just draw a line draw a line
yeah sure then i develop various
notations for symmetrizations and then
you can do symmetrizations on top of
anti-symmetrizations and this is very
useful in many areas of physics and
mathematics and um but i had a good
friend denis sharma
who who i got to know primarily because
he was a friend of my brothers oliver
oliver was at cambridge doing physics
and i was doing an undergraduate degree
in london
university college london in mathematics
which included
applied maths which which is a lot of
physics in that
but i remember being inspired by a radio
talks by fred hoyle
and fred hoyle was i think there are
about five of them he started with the
earth and then he moved out and moved
out and moved on cosmology
and eventually talked about the steady
state model which he and bondi and
gold had developed
because there was a paradox in those
days about cosmology
because people had worked out the age of
the universe
and they'd also worked out the age of
certain clusters of stars called
globular clusters
and the globular clusters were older
than the universe
which was seemed like a paradox and so
the steady-state model
emerged out of that so well the big bang
was not really the beginning at all
and you had a steady state model it was
actually due to mistake because they
the astronomers had mixed up two types
of uh
variable stars cepheid variables and
and they've got the wrong ones and
therefore they got the universe too
young
but but that wasn't known at the time
right and uh
hoyle was describing this in his radio
talks he was said
when the the galaxies recede from us and
they receive you so you need them to
recede
and then in the gaps between the galaxy
you get new material hydrogen produced
popping up i guess in that approach
right yeah that's right it was a clever
idea
and it was wrong but it was a clever
idea and uh
i quite liked it and i heard fred
talking about the remote galaxies as
they uh well you see when they got
faster than light they would disappear
so he said they would just appear when
they got faster than night
i thought this is a little strange and i
started drawing little pictures with
like cones and
and what i really saw what happened is
that they didn't disappear they just
faded away
gradually they got dimmer and dimmer and
dimmer
and so i was visiting cambridge and i'm
visiting my brother
in the kingswood restaurant and i was
sitting down having
having lunch with him and i
explained my puzzle to him about the
galaxies disappearing
and he said well i don't know about
cosmology but sitting on the table over
there
is a good friend of mine dennis sharma
and he knows about cosmology and he'll
he'll tell you the answer you see so i
went and talked to dennis
and i drew my little pictures with the
light cones and and he hadn't seen this
before
and he said well i don't know about that
but i'll talk to fred and ask him
but apparently this made an impression
on him but when i did go to cambridge as
a graduate student
dennis was absolutely he sort of got
hold of me and said look
you've got to learn about physics and
awful lot of physics and cosmology
and he used to drive me uh to
visit uh stratford for the
play the shape shakespeare plays and
things like that so we used to go
quite commonly and he would drive at
great speed around these
windy roads to test relativity no doubt
exactly because it was this mark's
principal he was a great fan of
principles who said that you were the
rotating bucket
well it was but this was he was the i
mean he was going to go around the
wrong great the side of the car i said
no that's
that's the action of the fixed stars
[Laughter]
that was his so without the stars you
wouldn't have felt that centrifugal
force just now as you whipped around
that's right so we thought look
supposedly remove the stars one by one
one more then what would it be like what
would happen to the election would you
be determined by the car then you'd take
the car to pieces what's left you see
now that was quite an important uh
influence on me
indeed yeah just i don't want to go a
diversion too much but
do you do you agree with that
perspective do you think that without
the distance
stars if you were to rotate you wouldn't
feel uh i'm
not sure about that well it doesn't
einstein never i mean it was a big
influence in his
origin of the theory but it never really
worked right
within with his model no i'm i'm not
really proponent of
that scheme but it did it did lead to
this scheme of
spin networks yeah which was you just
whittle it down to a few
few spinning particles and how do they
know how they're spinning and so on
yeah so it influenced me in that
direction so what then pushed you in the
direction
of of thinking about what we now they
weren't called black holes
well it was 1958 i'm getting better
this was when i was back as a research
fellow and dennis said
i i'd already got interested in
relativity at that time
um because dennis was i think and then
he said well look
come with me to a lecture given by this
fellow
david finkerstein at king's college
london
and so i went and and david was
explaining
how with the famous solution called the
schwarzschild solution which describes a
spherical body
in einstein's theory and we usually just
think about the vacuum
outside the body because chartreuse also
had a way of describing the matter
inside but that wasn't so important
it's really the outside but then you
imagine squashing this body down and
down and down
until it reaches this scale
which is called the schwarzschild radius
and at this short short radius if you
look at the
formula the the equations you see it
just goes crazy at that point
and it looks as though you've got a
singularity that is to say
looks as though things go to infinity
and zero and just doesn't make any sense
i think we have that equation we can
probably bring it up
as you're talking yeah at this r equals
2m in inappropriate units when the
radius reaches what's called 2m
in in in appropriate units and for the
sun i forget it's just a
few kilometers yeah three kilometers for
the sun two kilometers or something yes
um for the earth i don't know about that
big or something
a couple centimeters yeah yes and uh
but but people thought in those days
well you never would squash anything
down that far so so
what's the problem but fingerstyle's
talk was was a more theoretical one
and he was describing how if you change
the coordinates
the sort of infalling ones and then the
like cones are tipping over like this
then you get rid of that singularity and
i was very impressed by this
at the end of it he talked to me and i
told him that's been
spin networks and he told me about
relativity and he sort of swapped
subjects he considered because he was
working
i was working on combinatorial physics
and then i changed it in relativity and
he changed from generativity to
combinatorial physics
what an impact you both had on me but
anyway
i thought when i came back from the
lecture i thought well gosh he's got rid
of that singularity r equals two f but
that's still the one in the middle
maybe there's a theorem of some sort
which shows you can't get rid of this
you push them this way in that way but
you just got rid of it
i thought what do i know about general
relativity i mean i've never seen
anything like that
what do i know about general relativity
that other people don't know
and maybe might miss you know just sort
of
some way of looking at it what do i know
well i know about
two components spinners and why did i
know about them because i was playing
without
general sort of tensor systems and
usually in an algebraic way and with
these diagrams and all that stuff
and i couldn't see how the spinners fit
into this and so dennis
gave me an incomprehensible book by
course and really a good book
much of information in it but it was
very incomprehensible
but then curiously enough very strangely
i went i think at that stage when i was
in first year as a
as a fellow i went to the second
core second part of the course of
quantum mechanics given by
paul dirac i leaned to the first part of
the course
when i think it was an undergraduate
then i went to the second part of the
course and curiously in the middle of
this course
he deviated from his standard uh
exposition and talked about two
component spinners
now i i just thought this is great for
fortune but
i learned afterwards talking to people
who went into
direct in i think there was a biographer
or something who was
i was talking to a woman who was working
on his early papers
and uh she said it was most unusual for
direct i think it was she or maybe it
was graham farmer
who told me it's most unusual for for
direct to deviate from his course
so i don't know but it happens that
dennis sharma was his only graduate
student
around about that time and i think he
possibly mentioned that
if he talked about two spinners there's
somebody who might be interested in him
but he did he gave a very very clear
two or three lectures on it made
absolutely clear to me
and so that was the thing i knew and i
knew
that you could you basically you split
your tensor index into two and
one's a spinner and that's the complex
conjugate of it
that's a very beautiful idea um but then
i thought well let's
try and apply this idea to general
relativity i haven't seen anybody do
this before
and it works amazingly well i'm quite
surprised how well it worked
and you could the main point was you've
got a very good
understanding of the viral tensor you
see the curvature tensors they're called
the riemann tensor
and it splits into two pieces and
one of these pieces is called val
w-e-y-l
bile tensor and this the richie tenses
the other part
and that part describes directly the
matter
so it's likely charge in
electromagnetism
in electromagnetism maxwell's equations
you have the charge
current vector which is the source then
you have the maxwell field
which is the field so the maxwell field
is the photons if you like now with
quantized things
it's the electromagnetic field that's
how we can see each other
without maxwell we wouldn't be here we
wouldn't be seeing each other so
or we wouldn't understand why we're
seeing each other well you wouldn't
people wouldn't
know how to do it i guess that's true
too i mean i think it's it's important
to
huge huge revolution in physics up
quite unrecognized to the degree it is
by the general public i think yep huge
revolution but anyway that's not the
thing i'm mentioning here
but in the einstein theory you could do
a similar thing you have the richie
tensor
which is the source and then you have
the vial tensor which is likely maxwell
field
and when you write it in spinners it
looks the equations look just about the
same
it's got two more indices but it's just
four instead of two
and it's a very similar equation so i
really
understood about how the
curvature acted on light rays
because of the spinners and that was
very useful to me
right all this is sort of background and
this is
much earlier this is 58 right um
i can ask you one question on on that
before we get into the details of what
it is that you
use this technology to to prove you said
that
you're at figelstein's talk and he shows
that the singularity at the horizon at r
equals 2g m over c squared that that
is just a coordinate singularity that's
not a real singularity by changing your
description
you can show that the math doesn't blow
up no problems there and then you said
that you said but there's still this
other singularity at r equal to zero
at the center of the solution that
schwarzschild gave us
and you said that your motivation was to
figure out some way of proving that that
singularity could not be gotten rid of
but
most of us most of us sort of approach
things the other way right was like we
want to get rid of singularities right
well it's not the question what you want
it's a question of what's true but what
was motivating you to think that you
couldn't get rid of that singularity
i don't know i mean it's the same the
thing is the curvature there is an
infinite that's true yeah
it goes like one over r to the sixth i
guess as r goes to zero right
for example like crazy yes you get to
the middle but of course that doesn't
tell you that if you had an irregular
case uh that was what i was thinking
about you know suppose you perturb it
does that singularity remain so
physically that would be rather than
just spherical stuff
falling in perfectly spherical all the
way it might have
an un a shape that's not symmetric and
then maybe
it wouldn't all collapse right at the
center so you wouldn't have a
singularity
that's right well you see as i learned
later but
this is you see i i didn't do much
after the finkelstein talk except
familiarize myself
um about spinners and how light rays
behaved
in accordance with the violin and richie
tensor you could see clearly the
difference between the two
which he just focuses it's like a
positive lens
and the vial is like a an asthmatic
lenses squashes and fletches like that
and so i you know i appreciated all that
stuff
but it wasn't till much later i guess in
the 60s now
when i was at princeton well i've been
at princeton
and i got to work on gravitational waves
john wheeler who was uh very interested
in gr and i think quantizing
was one of the things they were trying
to do there i didn't much care for the
way they were doing it um
then i went for i was a two-year
nato fellowship and for the half
well it was about a third of the second
year i went to syracuse university in
new york state
where there are an awful lot of
relativists there including
well peter bergman who had been
einstein's
last absolutely right and
then there were people like arthur comar
and well engelbert shooking was there
um and various other uh
anger troutman visited just after i went
there and
ted newman was the big ivor robinson
ted newman race sax i think was in the
army at that point but
but he did visit i remember talking to
him um
but ted newman i got to know very well
um and we developed
spinner sort of techniques for looking
at gr but
the the main thing was more um
later on when i started thinking i'm
i guess i was back in princeton again
later on
just trying to think how what the
ordering of this it was in london when
i was back in london when when the um
you see the point was the quasars had
become puzzling to people these were
these very bright
radio sources which seemed to be
not only 100 times brighter than an
entire galaxy
or whatever it was and uh very small too
i guess
it's more so smaller than the polar
solar system because they had variations
which indicated
you know that the speed of light to get
across from one side to the other
you they'd have to be smaller than solar
system and this was indicating to people
that you you
are looking as though you were down to
the scale of the schwarzschild
radius the aric equals 2m or you get it
with a
um constants in um
but just at that scale um you can see
uh you're
playing around with that scale let's
just say these act we've got physical
phenomena
which are probing that kind of scale so
various people including fred hoyle
and and uh
and his collaborators um we're looking
at the possibility of of
maybe gravitational collapse i don't
think they were thinking about
black holes in the sense we do know but
they certainly thought that
something funny was happening down at
this schwarzschild radius scale
which happened to be the case but but
they didn't know
what was going on but the whole question
you see
um i guess this was in in the 60s in
1960
uh 64 that's right and since 1964.
i guess i'd been to some conferences or
something about it and john wheeler had
worried me i thought well i can't drive
whether it was yes i must have been at a
conference then
and uh john wheeler was worrying about
whether the singularities were real or
not
yeah and the what there had been this
paper in 1939
uh by oppenheimer and snyder where they
studied
a dust cloud so this means it's matter
with
with no no pressure and it's
falling immediate completely
symmetrically in towards the center
spherically symmetrical to the center
and there you've got this singularity in
the middle which is infinite density
and this is a picture of a black hole
it's the one people use often
a black hole but people were suspicious
of this
for two reasons one was it was dust and
therefore no pressure that actually as
it turns out was not a good reason
because
pressure works the other way but that
that wasn't the point i mean
probably stronger actually yes that's
just that's
but then nevertheless the fact that
there's no pressure and somehow there's
nothing to stop the
particles coming together and the main
point is it's just focusing right into
the middle so of course you get a
singularity there's nowhere else to go i
mean it just
aims at the central point and this would
seem to be an artifact give it a little
bit of irregularity it's swished around
and called squarely on again
and this was given a lot of credence
particularly
because there was a paper by liscious
and kalanikov two russians
where they appeared who to have proved
that in the general situations you did
not get singularities
yeah these were only artifacts of
special
case secular singularities and and this
paper
was out in the in the journals and i had
a look at the paper i certainly looked
at it
but i didn't i didn't there was a
mistake in it which was discovered
i think by belinsky later on and he then
joined with the other two and they
corrected it but this is part of a
result of the work that we've
done to show that singularities are
actually quite generic
einstein himself also wrote some papers
oh yes yes no he i don't think einstein
you see let me finish the story here
because of course
um
yes yes yes
yeah let me finish this story and i'll
come back to what else i would have
thought because i think you're
absolutely right
um as some other people he probably
would have had a similar
let me come to that um the the
so i was trying to think what happens in
the general situation
and i believe liscious and kolachnikov
i looked at the paper i did not knowing
the mistake in it but i did
i just had the view that i didn't quite
see that you could
properly prove anything using that
method i mean maybe you could but
it wasn't it wasn't sufficiently
persuasive to me that they were right
and i thought quite likely it wasn't
true that you
did get singularities in a general
situation i remember walking in a park
i used to live next to a park and
walking in that and trying to imagine
myself in this collapsing material
and i came to the view that it had to be
that that if it was a local problem if
it getting
things get curvatures getting big they
just would go out again
but if it was something non-local some
non-local condition all the way around
in some sense
that it would have to be a condition of
that sort
now i i know what to do but i had for
another reason it's very there's a lot
of
coincidence in these things i had been
writing in
1964 another paper on something quite
different this had to do with the
asymptotic properties of fields
including gravitational fields
as you go out to infinity and what
happens at infinity and i had this
trick for conformally transforming
infinity
squashing it down into a finite region
n-rows diagrams that we now call
there's a much easier way of thinking
about what happens at infinity
as you don't think of it as infinity
because i was no good at doing all these
things with limits and
everybody was doing limits and orders of
magnitude and so on i didn't like that
kind of stuff so i've got geometry
squash it down and you can see where
infinity is
and and it was i could see it was a very
useful way of thinking about it
but the main thing was um this is now
not about infinity
but i was writing no sorry i was writing
this paper which was
about the papers infinity and i was i
got stuck
at one point because in order to prove
that the gravitational field behave in
the right way it's the sort of peeling
properties that ray sax had let's not go
into that here
there was a very beautiful way in which
the curvature
peeled off as you as you came in from
infinity really
and uh i had a nice way of looking at
that and she had to show that your
vile curvature your conformal curvature
had to be finite
at infinity and i couldn't quite prove
that
unless infinity had to be
spherical that is to say you've got
you look out of the sky and you see a
sphere out there if you think of that's
infinity
well there's that sphere and then
there's time so the
infinity is a three-dimensional space
which consists of that
celestial sphere in time but it's really
the one in the other way
you're looking out your lighter is going
out rather than coming in from
but it's the same picture so it's the
sky right out there
but i couldn't quite prove that it
worked if the sky had a funny topology
it might be a taurus you know i think
like a shape of a
surface of a doughnut um
or but then the proof didn't work
so i thought well that's this is a
nuisance i thought any any sensible
purpose person would say well just
assume it's a sphere of course it is
i thought well look maybe it's not it
would be maybe you can prove it's not
it's actually a sphere so i've developed
an argument
using looking at boundaries of futures
you take a
a point and you look at its future cone
so it spreads out
so this is currently in space time the
point makes this cone but then it's
going to cross itself
do all sorts of complicated things
but it still makes us fear if you
understand what these
the way these crossings and how they
behave and what the boundaries of
futures look like
so i got a good feeling i i sketched out
a proof in the appendix i it was a bit
sketchy but
i think it's essentially okay but um
the point was i got familiarity with
what boundaries of futures looked like
right and so then i the next part of the
story
was when i was back in england and i was
working at birkbeck college and a friend
of mine this is ivor robinson who was
who's an englishman
but and he was working in he headed a
department relativity in dallas
texas which was at the wasn't part of
the university of texas
at that time but it was an institute and
he was i don't know what he was talking
to me about but he had a wonderful way
of speaking and
the americans all loved him because he
had this what he did have a wonderful
way with words there's no question about
it
and he was talking to me like this and
just all of a sudden he waved his arms
around like this
i was walking down the street going
towards where my office was
yeah walking down the pavement the
sidewalk
and then we got to a crossroad and as we
crossed the road
we had to look out for traffic so the
conversation stopped
and then we got to the other side and he
started talking again again like just
like this
then when he left i started thinking i
got this strange feeling
of elation that something something that
clicked
just as i crossed the street i didn't
think it was crossing [ __ ] i had to go
through all the things in the day
what was it was it something i had for
breakfast was it
walk i'd done later or what was it this
or that no no
then it came back oh it's crossing the
street i know what it was
so i had this idea of what happens when
you're just
inside what you now call the horizon
the light rays you imagine a two two
dimensional surface so it's just like a
balloon
and then this balloon there's a flash of
light on the surface of the balloon
and that flash of light if you normally
think if it's like an ordinary
spherical spherical-like balloon with
the ones concave and the other convex
but on the concave side the light would
converge on the convex side it would
diverge
but if this balloon were inside just
inside
surrounding the material and just inside
what we call the horizon
the light rays on the outside would be
coming in as well
and so they both be converging and if
they were both converging
you don't need it to be actually
spherical it can be an irregular balloon
but if you light rays are converging on
both sides
then from what i knew about the futures
of
boundaries that you'd have a compact
boundary and
i can knew that you could prove
something from that that you'd have to
have a singularity
so that was a trap the trap surface that
you were able to it was the trap surface
which was the key
to characterization of a collapse which
has gone too far
right and it's not a local
characterization because you can have
trapped surfaces locally you can you
take two
pass light cones and they intersect in
which is locally trapped so there's
nothing wrong with it being
but it's trapped locally but all the way
around
and that's the problem and when you get
that
you have a singularity so the proof as
long as the
energy density that is to say the light
rays
there's a general tendency for them to
focus inwards
if the richie tensor is
has a positive focusing property that
means positive energy
so if it's n or non-negative right well
not to be
zero is still all right if it was
negative that would wreck the theorem
so your nobel prize winning result you
actually came to by following this
sense of elation yes reconstructing
during the day when it happened yes and
extract
have you had other moments of elation
that
i haven't had one that i'd forgotten
that's i think the only time i'd
forgotten i'd have to
no i have had i have had ideas which
i've forgotten and resurrected that's
true
right yeah yeah that's an amazing story
that's an amazing story quite like so so
you write this paper
where you write up what you just
described to us so so beautifully
what was the reaction well that's what i
was
come back thinking my other question
which is again singularities are usually
the kinds of things that we teach our
students
throw away the solutions that are
singular those are the non-physical ones
here you see of course there were people
who didn't believe me
i had a remember a a letter from
um jim badi's son well you know what his
name is
jim bardeen yes no not not the one who
got two nobel prizes
yes no he he wrote me and told me that
my proof was all wrong
so i had to tell him that you
misunderstood there were people who
thought he was wrong technically there's
an error or they're just saying we don't
believe it i mean like a technical error
they were claiming i don't think they
just didn't follow it
okay um there was one very good reaction
which was from charlie misner
who actually gave me a better proof
there was one part of my proof which was
messy and he said why didn't you do it
this way i knew i knew that argument i
just hadn't thought of using it
so i said nice thank you i hadn't
thought of that
so that so my laser description it's not
the one given in the paper in my later
descriptions you
use charlie's improvement right that was
just a technical point which made it
better
didn't change the argument particularly
it's
it made a much neater way of do doing it
so that was that reaction
but let me give you another reaction i
remember i was in princeton
this must have been following that uh
and i remember
going into the lecture room and find
hold of wherever it was there
and uh and bob dickey came in and
slapped me on the back and said
he was very pleased with result oh
you've really done it now
you you've shown you've shown general
relativity is wrong
yeah so a lot of people that was their
reaction
because you get these singularities
general relativity is wrong
and bob dickey was very keen on this
because he had his
objective theory trouble
the theorem works in his theory too so
it wasn't much of a
a a resolution of his problem
but um let's go back to einstein
so einstein was highly skeptical of
short style solution and so forth
because he died by then he died of them
but of course but he was highly
skeptical what do you think einstein's
reaction
i think he would have thought general
relativity is wrong
really inspect i mean there's quite a
lot yeah i think i remember
also um um philip morrison phil morrison
yeah i remember talking to him about it
and he said oh yes i mean he
he didn't believe in black holes and all
that and you thought it was wrong in
general
but he was wrong i didn't realize he
thought it was gr was wrong
but it wasn't such a well established
theory at that time
i think i mean of course there was the
nobel prize won by
by taylor um
yeah yes that's right yeah for the spin
down rate
that's right spin down i mean that that
was impressive because that really
showed that they
it agreed with gr and gravitational
radiation
yeah so so had einstein thought of your
argument
back say in 1915 or so he might have
discarded
the general theory of relativity
that's an interesting point it took a
long time before people were you see
there was a long time for people really
thought you got
right down to that level it took the
quasars you see really
well you have to go back to
chandrasekhar too yeah because there
were
studies of uh that was the work chandra
sega did on the boat when he was
19 or something going to cambridge or
something from india or something we're
going to cambridge yes
and he did this calculation to show that
that
that white dwarfs were unstable if they
were more than about one and a half
times the mass of the sun
right they would collapse yes yeah so
he'd already showed that
and and he realized there was a problem
and he i think in his paper
he was very modest about it he just said
this leaves us
pondering on other possibilities or
something like that right
so now obviously you you you didn't
think that this proved that
the general theory of relativity was
wrong you know this is just revealing
equality
that's not a theory yes um uh now black
holes were not
yet um call black holes at that point
but how did john wheeler the man who
coined the term
black hole or popularized it what was
his reaction to your proof oh he he was
very pleased with it yes i think he he
thought it was a
no i think people who were really into
relativity and weren't
prepared to give i mean they obviously
were prepared to give it up
in the sense of arguing that when you
reached a level when quantum mechanics
right impact on gr and that
you might expect not to happen until you
had radii of curvature
of 10 to the minus 33 centimeters so
you're looking at 10 orders of magnitude
smaller than the an ordinary particle
right uh 10 to the minus 13 10 to the
minus 33
what are we talking about 20 yeah well
it depends if you call 10 to the minus
18 or so
maybe the radius of a proton then you're
looking at 10 to the you know 15 orders
of magnitude smaller but yeah
yeah sure that's right 10 to 15. you
know if you're looking at sort of
nuclear forces that's right so you're
looking at tiny tiny
things way beyond the sorts of physics
we're worrying about normally
right if you have a gravitational
collapse then you're faced with this
sort of problem
you will is that what goes wrong
and in my paper i just say oh well
something goes wrong and we don't know
what it is
right i think i did i can't remember
what i said about quantum
yeah yeah you did mention that quantum
mechanics might be
the resolution to it but but your paper
wasn't black holes per se it doesn't
talk about event horizons it's really
talking about
inevitability of these singularities so
so were you thinking black holes as the
place where your theorem would really be
realized in nature
well that was the natural thing you see
i remember giving a talk
yes well that's another part of the
story of course when i thought about the
theorem in the paper
i gave a talk at uh king's college
london in in late 1964
and uh despite what the movie says
stephen hawking was not there
oh the uh the the theory of everything
movie that's right
who the person was there was jl singh
who was a distinguished
uh relativist who had this very
geometrical way of looking at i liked
his book very much because it had this
geometrical
way of thinking which which was my way
of thinking too um
and he was there at the talk he just
happened to be visiting london i think
i was pleased he was there um but what
the thing that worried me a bit is that
it proved you had singularities
but you couldn't necessarily see them
because
they seemed to be hidden by this horizon
didn't mean that they were necessarily
and you might imagine
more extreme situations such as a cursed
solution which
which rotates see the normal rotating
generalization of the schwarzschild
solution for with rotation is the cursed
solution
and this nice exact solution but you can
have an angle
an angular momentum parameter and a mass
parameter
and if the angular momentum gets too big
then you lose the horizon and you get
what you
call a naked singularity which you could
actually see
the singular point and the question
arose
might you have those situations sure
you'd be likely to get the black holes
but there might be more extreme cases
where you could get naked singularities
and the theorem i proved didn't
distinguish between the two it didn't
say
you necessarily got i mean you you
actually looking at the
perturbing this virtual solution so you
expect that the
in those cases you would retain the uh
the horizon but there might be other
cases where you where you
didn't necessarily which was worse it'd
be worse than black holes
but i think i thought postulated this
thing that i call cosmic censorship
which was that that black holes were you
know
forbidden to be seen they were censored
by the horizon right
now that has not been proven right i
mean disprove no
i think it's still a generic situation
i remember i went to a talk 20 years ago
by salt tukulski where he was doing work
on these light ellipsoid mass
sources for gravity and he claimed that
you could have
the singularity popping out beyond the
horizon but then i guess there's been
more recent work which has shown that
that's actually not
true in that case so yes well i think
you see you can get
specific particular solutions well i
think the the horizon the node from
the charge right the charged version of
the short shift solution the rise in the
noise from solution
if it's like the curve with too much
rotation
here you have too much challenge yeah
then again
you get a naked singularity right
questions can these ever be realized
yeah you get solutions but the question
is are they generic would they survive
general perturbations right and that's
what's not proved
right and i thought that to costly thing
certainly doesn't violate that
as far as i as you say i don't think
it's yet established
right so so as observational work
progressed and you know andre guez
you know uh who has won the prize with
you as the observations began to
establish the existence of black holes
did you feel vindicated
like this is yeah i think so
i was really glad to see i think whether
the earliest what was the earliest one i
forget there was
the double star wasn't it which looked
as though it was a black hole
oh i'm not even sure i know what that
one is um the double star system which
was the first
persuasive indication yes it's sort of
sucking
there one there was a a big red charge
or something yeah and it was accreting
onto a smaller mass and
you could see the effects of the
accretion i see
pretty cool you see i used to go to
these
uh texas conferences
yeah i went to them one of those ones i
i went to the first one where that's
where roy kerr
talked about his solution right
but then i think this is yes that was it
was stimulated
it was really the angle about shocking
um
rival robinson alfred shield got
together and said we need
to bring the relativists and the
astrophysicists together
because they're really evidence for for
the
general relativity playing a big role in
gr it was still a lot of people were
skeptical of it for a long long time
but i could see they used to invite me
often
several times at least to give torture
talks on black holes which i did a few
times
and uh like it was nice to see how
gradually and the beginning people were
very skeptical i think it was a very
small minority who really thought these
things were really there
and then gradually they built up and you
could see until it was about fifty
percent of them zoomed off
the other side the majority of people
were accepting them after that point
right it took quite a long time for them
to take
pick up on them yes and when the uh when
the event horizon telescope
actually showed what we like to call a
photograph presumably that's a
pretty uh pretty stunning stunning
moment you spoke about elation
as your experience of this
idea that you were able to thankfully
reconstruct
when you got the call about the nobel
prize with that also a moment of elation
or is that a different uh
glorious combination of things which
which kind of spoiled the event by the
time i heard about it
oh really well yes because when people
ask me what were you doing you said what
were you wearing or something
but actually was probably the first
indication was in my i was in my
birthday suit
because because i was having a shower
and the phone rang and this was patrona
my who's my
pa and she told me she just had this
strange phone call
from somebody who wanted to know my
phone number and she said i don't give
out your phone number to strangers and
said what's it about and they wouldn't
say what it was about
and it was somebody from sweden you see
so she slightly smelled the rat i think
and said well isn't it
about a prize and she's i'm i can't tell
you anything about it i'm afraid
yeah but she wanted my phone number so
then
i called patrona back and she said
um i said well you might as well give
her the phone number because
if you give it to me an iphone it's not
not any different so sure
so then a little while i waited for a
bit and then i got the phone call and
that was from
for one month she said well the the
president of the
um swedish academy of sciences wants to
have a word with you
and so would you hang uh hang on for a
bit then she said well i'm afraid he's
not available at the moment i think he's
trying to get hold of
the people in america and
germany um but um
she she
she sort of hung up and then then the
phone rang again and this time it was
the
the president of the academy of sciences
and he started talking to you a bit
and then in the middle of the
conversation he hadn't mentioned the
nobel prize in the middle of the
conversation he said oh
excuse me i think i i have to can you
hang on
so i hung on the phone i just waited and
waited and waited and waited
wait i didn't know what this is about
but if it's important you'll call me
back so i hung up
but then he did call me back eventually
told me it was a nobel prize but by then
i was beginning to get pretty suspicious
about all these things i wonder if
you're the first laureate to ever hang
up
on me i don't know
it was quite a long time i mean if it
had been only a minute i was being on
still like several minutes yeah
that's fantastic the ceremony has not
yet happened or or they're doing it by
zoom or andrea
i don't know how they do it for most of
them in my case
since i'm the only one in who's actually
resident
in uk there are three other
british british is it two in chemistry
and one in in
no one in chemistry i've gone between
numbers yeah sorry
two uh there's biology isn't it this
yeah there's biology
two two two biology which would be uh
jennifer doudna
and chippendi but they're they're all
elsewhere i think they're in the us
so so i would have been the only one
yeah
so what they've i mean they are giving
me a car
to take me down next week
and to to the to the embassy or the
residence of the of the
ambassador i see okay with my wife and
my son
very nice and that's that's that'll be
the audience i guess
yeah it's an unusual time unfortunately
but uh it doesn't take away from the
the honor in any way and congratulations
on that
can we shift gears to talk a little bit
about cosmology
is that uh sure yeah well it's it's a
natural progression
yeah it is of course i guess so i guess
to connect the dots because stephen
hawking who
wasn't actually at that lecture but
certainly uh at a subject yeah well i
should continue that because dennis
heard about the lecture yeah and he got
hold of me and said would you like to
give a repeat in cambridge
right she did so you know this was in
early 65
right then then steven was at that talk
and more importantly i had a private
session with stephen
and and george ellis maybe brandon
carter
i can't remember certainly george was
there and
so we had a long session together and i
just talked about the details of the
methods i was using and stephen picked
up on it very quickly
and the first thing he did was to use my
exact theorem but in the reverse time
direction
and using not for local but for very far
off
right and it was it was a clever idea
i hadn't thought of using it
i was thinking it was a local it's not
doesn't have the power when you use it
at the distance because you have to
assume you have a coaching surface
which is space-like which is um
non-compact
right and of course that's less uh
i mean for a local thing you can assume
it goes off to infinity so that's fine
right that's for for a cosmological
model it doesn't have quite the force so
so steven then developed the techniques
and made many many uh advances
um on these techniques and he had a lot
of help from brandon carter i think
because there was a occasionally there
were
um mistakes in the argument there were
what i call mistakes with the first kind
the second kind i just say you just find
a new way around them and it's fine it
still works
right so there were never any any
mistakes with the second
error so to speak yes and there were
some even in the thesis which
which was dennis and i were examiners of
him and
um you you were examiners for
for stevens it's not like in the film
where
cape thorne was there kip thorne was not
there
no it was just the two of us but i'd say
there were a few mistakes but i was
going to point them out to stephen in
the
in the oral but he'd see he he found
them all already
no you know he'd done it was an amazing
piece of work he'd done
four different topics and i said in the
account well any two of them would
be good enough for a phd right but the
the last one was that was on the sink
only the last one was on the singularity
cosmological singularities and then we
got together
he did three papers in the royal society
and there were certainly
significant advances particularly on the
uh getting rid of the koshi surface
condition which i think was perhaps the
most significant
thing he did was looking at kosher
horizons and their properties
and um no i think we did a lot of good
work on that that's clearly true
so the general conclusion was that under
fairly generic conditions
cosmology would have to have a big bang
like singularity much as a black hole
has a central singularity that's right
right
yes well the next part of the story is
was i was in princeton
you see yeah i was in princeton and
we were about to go off to a meeting in
stevens institute
in hoboken just across the river from
new york
sure and lots of people from
new york state were that was a thing
that was going
they were going on for many years they
had important meetings
and uh people from princeton would go up
going up there and they you had to drive
out in various cars
and i noticed in the back of one of the
cars was in the middle i think was jim
peebles
and of course last years
and of course this was a long time
before that and
i asked him i said since i took the
opportunity of making him an asking
impression there was no room in the car
like i didn't
go up with him but i said why don't you
there's all these different solutions
you come up with much more complicated
than ones you consider in cosmology why
don't you look at all these other
complicated kinds of models and he
looked at me and he said
because the universe is not like that
and i thought
my god it's not like that is it
i think he was talking he was thinking
about the cosmic microwave background
and the evidence of how uniform it is
and so it's a singularity of
great uniformity it's not like any of
those messes
and this was a great a moment of
revelation to me because
i thought gosh now you've got to explain
why up to that point it was
as you say the arguments for
singularities
work just as well in the future as in
the past future singularities past ones
futures black hole singularities past
ones
but it's very different and if the idea
would be it's quantum gravity if it
solves the problem
but then that doesn't make any sense but
if it's quantum gravity why does quantum
gravity tell you you've got this
extraordinarily uniform initial state
and this great massive and it's all tied
up with second law of thermodynamics
and there's a clear point that the
uniformity
means that the gravitational degrees of
freedom
we're not activated and the second
that's what drives the second law of
thermodynamics is really fundamental to
physics
so highly ordered gravitational degrees
of freedom that then can become disorder
yes what is the the vile curvature so
this is again the biochemistry
if you think of vial curvatures
describing gravity which was not
really the way many people thought of it
but that was the way i thought of it
vile curvature is the gravitational
field
and that is zero at the beginning i mean
we don't know if it's exactly zero but
it's
it's suppressed right and the fact that
you get this uniform vowel curvature
zero initial state
and then allows you to have the
potential to clump
into clouds of gas stars
galaxies sun
and we get our energy from the sun
in a low entropy form i mean that's the
whole point that schrodinger
pointed out very crucially
we don't get energy from the sun because
it all goes back again apart from global
warming but that's a small effect as
we get as much energy from the sun as we
as we shoot back out again but the
difference is
we get it in a low entropy form and it
goes out in a high entropy form so it's
small number of photons coming in
spread out over many many photons going
out yeah i think 20 times as many
photons out has come in typically
yeah something like that and that's
really what we live on
it's it's the entrance in there and
that's because the sun is a hot spot in
the dark sky
and it's a hot spot in the dark sky
because it clumps from gravity
and that's where all life and everything
where it all comes from this
fact that we have this
low entropy in gravity even though it's
high in everything else
so i had no idea why this is and i
thought gosh it must be some very
peculiar
theory of quantum gravity because it's
some very peculiar thing which is so
grossly asymmetrical in time
that was the view i held for a long time
and it must mean
that um the theory is crazy
but probably crazy anyway but very crazy
because it's so different in the past in
the future
right and then i formulated this thing
called the vile curvature hypothesis
just a hypothesis
just says in singularities in the past
type
pretend there aren't any space like ones
that would be cosmic censorship violated
then you've got two kinds past kinds
future kinds
and just different future kinds are a
great mess
vile curvature running wild maybe
there's where kaletnikov
and polinski and this shits are right
right possibly i don't know if they're
right or not it's quite possible but
absolutely wild kind of behave
in the future absolutely crazy and ms
misner did the
same sort of analysis and
that's uh very possibly the sort of
thing you get
why is it so different is it just
quantum gravity crazy quantum gravity or
is it something else
right now while this is going on
we're developing more conventional
cosmological ideas
i'd love to hear about your more
maverick recent thoughts on how to
incorporate this
cosmos can i first have your thoughts on
on
the like inflationary cosmology you and
i have actually had conversations about
this in the past and i know that you
know
i knew it was anything i heard about it
and i it just made me feel ill whenever
i
saw it because well i mean i i knew it
you have this problem i mean my my
outlook on it was different from other
people's you see i think many people
were worried about the
scale and variance of the of the
background
which is a big feature and i couldn't
see how to explain it and that's sure
and inflation was an attempt to that
wasn't the main reason it was put
forward
initially but never mind it was
certainly uh
something and it's in favor but it was
to my mind
a very ugly theory if i may
be hard to say that because you had to
invent this field the infotainment field
which had this very specific it only was
invented for this one purpose
so it had to have this peculiar kind of
shape of its potential curve and it just
just to make it do this what you're
supposed to do
and it didn't solve my problem and which
you could see quite easily because you
just think of collapsing universes
and you can put an infotainment field in
just as well reverse time
so many people in inflation view the
implaton
field as more of an existence
argument or a toy model for a cosmology
in which you'd have repulsive gravity
early on because of the
pressure being sufficiently large as we
were talking about before
and and so the real quality of
inflationary cosmology i think most
people hang
their hat on is a period of accelerated
expansion in the early universe
regardless of how
it comes about the infotom field just
being one toy model if you will
that doesn't resonate with you at all
though it doesn't help
you you know i mean you could put that
in whatever it is and then you
you see you had this mess at the end and
nothing
i mean it doesn't work i mean unless you
put
asymmetrical physics in i mean time is
asymmetric right no okay then my my
claim
my argument would fail but i didn't see
that in any of the
schemes that people put forward they'll
just say when you know when
curvatures get big or blur something
right
not telling you anything which
i think most people would say we put in
you know the so-called past hypothesis
that for reasons that we can't really
explain you had low entropy
initial conditions and of course that's
the puzzle that
one wants to explain and then if you
imagine that
there's accelerated expansion forever
into the far future
then you get the time asymmetry not from
the fundamental laws but from the
solution
where you'd have this but you're
choosing a
this is my picture of the deity
a little pinprick in the 120 possible
10 to the power 10 that's true yeah
124 whatever it is yes sure yeah well
that's that's
i mean that's just you need a theory you
don't need to
no it just seemed to me that's that's
the wrong picture
right but i just i thought you had have
a crazy quantum gravity
i didn't like the idea but it i couldn't
see i i thought it probably you need it
for just
make the reduction of the state vector
too which you probably do but that's not
with a crazy theory like that
right but what about the idea and it
comes what about the idea that people
like
andre linde and others have developed in
various guises where you imagine that
early on
you had some chaotic state where the
infoton field might be wildly
undulating and then just it just so
happens that in a tiny region
maybe 27 centimeters across the infoton
field just happens to get a uniform
value
allowing for the negative pressure that
can drive the repulsive gravity
what about that idea well i've described
this in my book fashion fashion fantasy
yeah i got this initial state which are
all like that occasionally gets this
little tiny smooth bit
right okay what's the likelihood of that
whether you've got 10 to the 10 to the
10 to the minus 24. okay well how about
making universe which is only about as
big as our galaxy
right that's even more probable right
it's much much much much much more
probable than the
other one right so we're going to do it
by that argument
why do we see our universe keeping on
going
going it's not just done for our galaxy
our life
yeah ongoing and going and going right
and it doesn't even help to make you
could say okay well
you made me need lots of them to get
human beings or whatever it totally
makes sense but but again some would say
that
maybe one's being too quick and
conflating small measure
with small probability i mean because
certainly
in the space of all possibilities we're
talking about
a very small measure to give rise to the
universe
in that formulation but how do you know
that small measure
means small probability there could be
some other fundamental principle
that wouldn't have the something guiding
the creator's pin into it
into this right the region for some
other reason sure
you might have but it's not it's not the
right theory well you need a theory for
that
yeah so tell us what you've been
thinking about yeah you see this was the
the other ingredient to this discussion
again i was thinking you see i had this
picture of infinity squashing it down in
the future to make
nice description of and i was just
thinking about how boring the universe
is
in our picture okay it's exciting now
all sorts of interesting things going on
some of them nice some of them horrible
but it's think of the remote future well
these supermassive black holes will
swallow up in
entire galactic clusters and then
they'll drift away from each other
and you just get these black holes black
holes they sit there and they sit there
and they sit there
eventually they evaporate away by
hawking i mean it's all really pretty
boring when you've just i mean
some people say black holes are exciting
but you get bored with them if there's
that's all there is in the universe
and uh and they just drift away from
each other and then they evaporate by
hooking them
that's really boring so then i thought
well
who's going to be bored by this universe
it's only mainly photons running around
that's most of what's running around and
these photons
don't get bored easily not just because
they don't have experiences in the
ordinary sense of word
but because the time progression
is zero for a photon it gets from here
by that to infinity to it in zero time
right so it's at this boundary which is
infinity
it reaches it and that's i think well
maybe there's something on the other
side of that boundary
well in the asymptotically fact it's now
but if you've got a cosmological
constant so
being convinced of the cosmological
constant which took a little while for
me because i had wrong reasons for just
believing in
and i think it was jerry ostriker who
persuaded me i remember we were going
into dinner somewhere
some college and i said to him well all
this stuff about the cosmological
council maybe maybe it's
just dust or something like that and he
looked at me and he said
that's not the point putting positive
lambda in there
solves an awful lot of problems in
cosmology it makes lots of things come
together
so okay accelerate expansion cmb
the critical density it all works
together so much better
okay you win cosmological constant
so that means space like infinity is
space-like so now i knew it was
space-like
now a lot of photons come and they hit
this space-like surface what's on the
other side
now i should explain just going a little
back
i had this vial curvature hypothesis for
the
initial big bang but my student paul
todd
who had been working on these things and
he
thought much white nicer way of phrasing
this
was not to say that but to say because
it's
it's unmanageable really because you
could say that the vile curvature
at a singularity is zero is a mess
because
if it's singular everything's going wild
anyway to say it's infinite
zero at the same time doesn't make much
sense but if you stretch it out
by this uh informal stretching
to make the bang into a nice finite
boundary infinity makes by a theorem of
helmet friedrich you can see that
future infinity isn't going to be nice
and smooth
space like by the past okay let's
postulate that it's nice and smooth
it doesn't quite give you the volcano
which hypothetically it makes the bar
character finite but that's
not bad but then i thought okay let's
take adopt that picture
and now when you match them it makes the
dark averages zero
because by helmet friedrich well by
various arguments
it's got to be zero on future infinity
and so if you match this to the big bang
then it's there on the other side now
you can see this completely crazy
completely crazy because on the one side
you've got
very very rarefied low density cold
colder and colder and colder and colder
yeah on the other side you've got
enormously hot density
enormously hot completely the opposite
what right do i have to match the two
right
now the argument is and there's a bit of
hand waving in this but
okay in the future
here's where most of the hand waving is
actually in the future it's mainly
photons
and photons have no mass photons
respect the conformal structure
equations maxwell's equations don't
notice if it's squashed or not the
equations
are conformally invariant so that the
maxwell field becomes perfectly finite
infinity
photons are fine what about the big bang
well now it's the opposite you have a
very very hot situation and now you're
stretching it out
the squashing of the future infinity
makes it warmer again
if you like more dense and warmer this
stretching
of the big bang makes it
uh much much colder and less dense
why are you allowed to do this because
you've got massive particles
no you haven't because the particles
when they move around they move around
faster and faster and faster
then by einstein z equals m c squared
this tells you that the
energy in the radiation
the mass if you like in the radiation
completely dominates
the mass is now completely irrelevant so
the particles in the big bang
are effectively massless which you get
right at the beginning
so there again they respect the
conformal geometry
so the future and the past if you take
this view
and this is where it's crazy but all
crazy things have been right in there i
mean
if you look out at the sun you see where
it moves around the sky
to say that the earth is moving not the
sun i mean that's crazy
and it's right but what if you have some
uh massive particles hanging around in
the far future
yes i mean as people have said to me
i remember gary gibbons saying that was
the weakest part of my theory
i said well yes it is it's part of my
theory but if that's the weakest part
i'm quite happy
that what i say is that and there is an
argument for this and it needs more
working on but the sort of argument is
what's the first thing people do in
particle physics when they
classify particles what they do
is they look for what are called the
casimir operators
of the poincare group now there's a
little bit of jargon here
poincare group is the group of
symmetries of special relativity
now what are casimir operators well
these are things
which are completely conserved and one
of these
in the ordinary theory of particle
physics of special relativity you see
particle physics
particle physicists usually consider the
physic they don't talk about gravity
you've got special relativity
and uh you've got the part of the
these um casimir operators which are
absolutely conserved
are mass and spin
now when you've got a cosmological
constant
you might argue that this isn't the
right group
the right group you put the cosmological
constant in it doesn't really play
much of a role until you've got this
exponential expansion starting to come
in and then
the group maybe you could say it's not
really the poincare group it's the
decisive group
and you look for the casimir operators
in the distinctive group and you see
that
mass is not a cosmetic operator now
this argument is not terribly strong one
it's just for me
it was where i say okay i don't have to
take
current particle physics that seriously
to say
that mass has to be an absolute constant
over
huge cosmological time scales
and i would argue for various reasons
that the lifetime
of the dark matter particles you see
this this is going a little ahead of
myself here
but you have dark matter as the main
constituent of material in the universe
that the dark matter particles would
gradually decay
and their decay would have a lifetime of
about
10 times uh 10 to the 11 years so that's
that's uh
another ten times the times the age of
the universe
of the universe so that's about the
lifetime
and these things would then decay but
you also have to have a
a mass this is just particles okay i'm
not arguing that the massive
the electrons would have to lose their
mass they can't decay because it's got
charge
right and they're so electron positron
annihilation but you need to get rid of
everything
that's right but they're not gonna they
they can't meet each other they get
separated
yeah and and you get you get hydrogen
but no the idea is that the mass itself
would have to fade out very very
gradually
right that doesn't have a proper theory
as it stands
so i would say gary givens is completely
right that's the weakest part of the
theory
but if that's the weakest part i'm quite
happy we need we need to work on that
and we need to see how the proper theory
of particle physics in this
cosmological context really works so in
this approach you really do imagine then
that it's a
cyclical process where the far future
attaches to the far
past it's a different person's father
right different person far past um so um
in terms of predictions for things that
might see if this theory is correct i
know you've written a few papers over
the years
what what's the state of things now i
know things have
been a as it settled do you have a sense
of what one would look for
i could think of three observational
features
the first one was the first one the
first one
that i thought about was circles in the
cmb that's right this is the
collisions with supermassive black holes
so if you have a galactic cluster
then the galaxies in the cluster
assuming that each one
has a supermassive black hole in it they
will gradually
collide with each other we will collide
with andromeda
in a little while a few thousand million
years i guess
and uh probably they were galaxies black
holes will spiral into each other and
they will
be one walloping explosion
in mostly energy will go out in the form
of gravitational radiation
this gravitational radiation will make
its
mark on the crossover between one eon
and the next and
this mark on eon is a cycle is that is
that what you call that
yeah yeah like i call it eon aeon
i looked up in the dictionary to see how
long an eon was because it didn't want
if it was a certain number of years that
was no good it wasn't
a certain number of years so i thought
okay i'll call it a neon
and i like to spell it with ae because
that looks fancier
and that's a choice that's allowed in
the dictionary i guess i uh yes yes
that's just
a lot of spelling so the a a the eon
starts from the big bang
and ends with this remote future
squashed right
you i've i've now made
it into this
compactified version big bang stretched
to
remote futures squashed that's one enon
then there's a next eon somebody after
us
and the next one and the next one and
there's one before us
and a black hole explosion
this is a collision between two black
holes form this
basically an impulse because it's in the
sort of time scales we're talking about
the spiraling in
is almost impressive yeah right with
this great impulse
coming out hitting the crossover this
will cause a
in this crossover surface what you've
got to wait for
380 000 years before you actually see
the effect of it
yeah and that's jim peeble's work
basically with his colleagues
in various places uh nobel prize last
time
what you do from big bang to
380 000 years and a point the big banks
stretching out to about eight times the
diameter of the moon here
now the rings would encounter this
with they'd be coming out and they would
start to
i will they will dis burst a little but
they pretty well remain
a delta function i think yeah and so you
look back at us
and you see this heating heating or
cooling it depends on whether it's
and it's it's counter counter intuitive
in a certain sense
but the most distant ones would
be blue shifted
that is the signal is coming towards us
and the closer ones will be redshifted
the signals going away from us
that's the way the geometry works so
that
um it's hotter and colder circles in the
in this that's right
now so people have looked people have
looked for those right so my
understanding is that they haven't
found we've looked and found them some
people looks and haven't found them it's
easier not to find them to find them
i'll tell you that
well you see i i the first people to
look where were were um david spurgle
and in princeton
yeah i remember at the 2000. he had a
look and he got
uh uh and to to do the analysis
they looked at it in a way which i
learned later was not terribly
appropriate but they started to see
signals at first and then realized this
was not right
then they got rid of them and then they
they didn't see any evidence of signals
i think that's quite fair um i suggested
twisting the sky at that point which was
a
way of seeing whether whether the
signals check i thought there was a
slight change in signaling but it wasn't
quite what i expected
so i didn't make any noise about that it
i agree that they didn't see any signals
right then
a little later on who's an armenian who
i knew from other things he'd done and
he'd showed me that
he'd looked for low variance rings
but the difference in the way he'd
looked at it you see the the way that
spurgle and and hadjian had looked was
to look for the over the whole sky
consider a radius ring and then look at
the temperatures and see where there's
non-garcianity in there right something
one random about the
over the sky and when they corrected for
the
things that were wrong they found that
there was no evidence for this that's
that's true
i'm not disputing that right but when
what showed me he was doing it
differently
he was fixing the center and then
looking
not for a high or low temperatures but
for lower variation in the temperatures
and he considered to have found a signal
i think and then since he was looking at
fixed centers with different rings
i said well look if you're doing it that
way maybe you will see
diff several rings with the same center
because if they would look see if it's
the same galactic cluster
that galactic cluster will compress into
one point
from our perspective and if these
collisions come several times
maybe one supermassive black hole
swallowing lots of others or several
explosions in the same
galactic cluster whichever it is they
would be
centered at one point so you've got
concentric rings got it
right so he then looked for concentric
low variance rings
and oh there was a lot of fuss about
this
i his analysis was done initially
in a way which was not considered
appropriate and i think
it was right probably not to consider it
appropriate
because he's not appropriately taken
into account
the usual procedure that people use
which is to
uh put in the the um
the curve the uh what's called the power
spectrum
you see what you do how do you know that
an effect is real or not
is it random or is it real well you make
a comparison with a lot of fake skies
so you make a thousand fake skies or
something now how do you know whether
the fake sky
is a a proper fake sky what do you say
you
say it's a fake sky which fits the same
power spectrum that's the dogma i mean
it's okay it's a pretty good dogma
it's at least you can you can use it and
you can bear it that's
that's you see for each
harmonic you see you've got these
different you imagine the sky is like a
drum and it
and it vibrates and has different
there's an overall
way of vibration which is called the l
value and with each
within each l value you've got the m
values which are the details of it
and the power spectrum is looking at the
l values okay
now you can use this l value and then
vary within the m values and why he
hadn't really done this initially so
they were right to criticize him on this
but then he did do it this way
eventually and
uh i can't quite see why uh the
criticisms are there
and he then tested this well twisted in
the sky
that was i thought quite a good way of
doing it you could see that when you
when you twist the sky
that the effect starts to go away and
the more you twist the more it goes away
so it's a favor it's favorite circles
i see but then the poles i'm going to
take polls i mean christoph meisner
pavel nyrovsky
and uh i've got the chain another poll
who did the analysis on the computer
analysis
they looked at the w see we only looked
at w map data
they looked at the w map data that's the
first of the satellites which you
really could look at the variations in
temperatures you uh looked at planck now
or
then we looked at planck well i should
say that
that the polls look at w map and they
found an effect
and they gave a probability of the
effect
which was 99.4 percent
ah this isn't the planck data i think in
the wmap data was 99.6 or seven i think
confidence level so it looked as though
there was something there everybody
ignored his paper
their paper um i'd never seen any
complaint of the analysis they did
uh then they did it for the planck data
and they found a 99.4 percent confidence
level
um and then and i did it a different way
by looking
there we had a lot of trouble with
referees and so on and
your your your claim at the moment is
that this theory's alive and well and
perhaps there is even
i should go to the next fact you said
yeah please because this is
this was already colliding black holes
one point
i was talking to christoph of this and
we talked to what where do we go from
here
and we decided we'd look for
i'd never dared to look for the hawking
points before
you see what happens to supermassive
black holes
they are well it may take 10 of the
goodness knows how many years before
10 10 to 103 years i think is what
don perry billion mouth solar mass black
hole 10 to 100 years or so
yes google years or something 100 years
that's a pretty long time
and in that length of time the radiation
will these biggest black holes will
evaporate entirely away
in terms of black or
mainly photons yeah now what does that
do in the crossover
well you just see what happens it's
squashed into a little point
it's useful to imagine these escher
pictures with angels and devils so
that's a nice conformal map and you can
see what infinity looks
everything gets squashed at the edge
right so all the radiation gets squashed
in this little teeny weeny point
so all the energy of that black hole all
the mass in that black hole is squashed
into that little point
now i never faced up to this because
this you talk about singularities that's
the singularity
in the crossover everywhere else you've
got nice smooth equations and you could
tell what happens as you go across
but here you've got one singular point
so you might throw up your hands but you
don't throw up your hands
because you can tell that there's a mass
there by doing an integral around it
so even when you cross over to the other
side you can't get rid of
there being a mass there so it's it
doesn't
depend on what theory you have
of what happens to this radiation in the
crossover so it'll be
that's where quantum gravity really
makes its mark
but what it does it doesn't make much
difference
it's just a burst of a huge amount of
energy in that tiny little point
now that spreads out to eight times the
diameter of the moon this is the
standard suffering
jim peebles and his colleagues worked
out for the
um 380 000 years so
eight times the damage of the moon you
should see slightly warm
spots okay well we have this paper
out i don't know about six months ago or
so
in the monthly notices of the royal
astronomical society
where we claim at 99.98
confidence level this is using
kristoff's analysis
these points are there also this is in
the planck data
also if you take the five strongest
points
and you look at where they are you look
at the wmap data
and you see points there in exactly the
same places
you find another one in the wmap data
and look back in the planck data
and it's there in the same place so you
have six points
which i think are genuine i'm not sure
whether the weaker ones are genuine
because the analysis which gives you
this high degree of probability
is only overall it doesn't tell you that
for any particular point
right have you heard from the microwave
background
experts around the world on on this one
it's a strange kind of conspiracy of
silence
i remember talking this is before this
paper i talked to christoph about this
and i said i think he said to me how
much how much response do you have on
your paper in the
european physical people i said zero
how about you and he says zero
so it's a conspiracy of silence but then
we it's not quite zero in the sense that
there's the
papers by um by douglas scott and
collaborators
and they uh they looked at the rings i
think
and claimed they saw that i was glad for
them to look at the rings because they
found the pictures looked almost the
same as vaj's people exactly the same
so they found the same distribution of
the rings and then they waved their
hands and said oh it's not not it's only
random
right but it's not random even if you
just look at it particularly if you look
at the centers
you look at the centers of the points in
the
plant data that's what's most
distinctive and what's more
this is i found very striking is what's
more
not only are they clumps in certain
regions
but they're clumped in temperature now
the temperature
gives you another parameter in various
analysis because you look for them
for low variance not because they're
warm or cool you look for them because
the
the temperature variance around the ring
sure and you look up for triples of
rings of low variance
temperature and then you plot the
centers and they're clumped
and they're clumped in temperature as
well as in variance so if you look to
the
um lower right hand part of the picture
you see a great region of red spots red
means warm which means blue shifted
which means distance
i hope i've got it the right way around
so that's a very distant region
technically in standard cosmology would
be outside what we call
our horizon so you shouldn't even see
them at all
but in this you can because you're
looking into the previous eon
you're looking further out than you can
see into our eon
right the at the top right you can see a
blue region
which is presumably within our uh
i don't know there should be some signal
seeing in the micro background in our
own i don't know i haven't tried it's a
curious it's a curious state of affairs
because you know
thinking science and sociology blending
them for half a second so the
inflationary theory
has been the dominant view for a long
time full disclosure i have to say that
i
am certainly in that camp that is the
way that i've long thought about things
but
but even paul steinhardt one of the
inventors of the inflationary theory has
now moved on
to create his own version of cyclic
cosmologies
and he now claims that inflation is not
as
secure as people claim it is
and now you've got another cyclic
approach which
is again heading off and again i just i
can't respond to any of the details of
what
you're referring to in the data i'm not
a cnb expert haven't looked at the
analysis but it certainly is um
if nothing else is an exciting time that
there are competing approaches to
thinking about
the deep question of how the universe
got to be and what the true nature of
the world is
uh so it is i mean yeah i mean i had
these arguments against inflation before
that was pretty
good but this model i think really is
hard
for inflation to model because not just
the hawking points
i mean you've got these really energetic
points
at the crossover yeah in this
conformally stretched big bang
and you've got to explain them you've
also got the clumping
both in temperature and and in
re in this region in the sky
which is surely goes against inflation
because that
says yeah of course and i think one of
them you say why haven't people seen the
hawking points before because they're
pretty
obvious probably yeah what do you think
the reason they haven't seen is just
haven't looked
people haven't thought well they're not
there because inflation says it must be
very uniform so why look for spots like
that
right i don't know but the cmb folks are
so
fastidious and so careful yeah analysis
but uh
but then it'd be interesting to see
where this where this all will go
certainly exciting
can we segue to a little bit of quantum
mechanics which is of course relevant to
everything we've been talking about
oh sure um you know so quantum mechanics
among you know one of the two great
descriptions of the world emerging in
the 20th century fantastically accurate
predictions
um you're of the perspective and i have
to say on this i fully agree with you
and it's my perspective as well that
quantum mechanics is not a done deal
quantum mechanics not a full description
because what we usually
call the quantum measurement problem um
do you want to describe that for a
moment because i have a few questions on
your perspective
on on the measurement problem what it's
telling us well my perspective i know
you shouldn't bring in names here but
einstein schrodinger and iraq all
believed
something had to be done about quantum
mechanics to deal with this issue
the issue is i mean people say quantum
mechanics is the
most wonderful theory in physics we've
ever had or something well it's a
wonderful theory
i don't like to call it that wonderful
because it's mutu
it's self-inconsistent now what do i
mean by that
well the schrodinger equation tells you
how the quantum state
evolves the quantum state is the way we
describe things in physics
there's a small caveat to that because i
might say what about the
density matrix matrix yeah i mean
that that's a little bit of a uh we can
put that to the side for now yep
put it aside it doesn't it doesn't solve
the problem right
but the problem is that you've got this
evolution of the quantum
state by the schrodinger equation
beautiful equation works
wonderfully when you can test it it
works actually perfectly
then what do you do with it well as
schrodinger himself
pointed out i mean he was very clear on
this although people take it the wrong
way in my view
he described this cat in the box he was
really saying look you could have a cat
in the box
according to my equation that's shorting
and talking if you like when he was
writing his equation
you could have an evolution of the cat
in the box in which it evolved to a dead
and a live cat at the same time
this is ridiculous there must be
something wrong with the theory
that was his viewpoint but people pick
it up and say oh no you could make it
if we had more and more best better
boxes better cats better
experiments or something you could make
a cat in the box which has been all at
the same time
but schrodinger was really pointing out
the absurdity of this situation which i
agree with einstein agreed
and even dirac although it's hard to
find
he was a man on a few words so he can't
he was
and he usually was very careful of these
words that he didn't say anything
that uh that he didn't totally have a
mathematical backup right this was the
case he didn't but he did certainly if
you find the right place you can find a
good quote from direct
sure but he did say there has to be
something wrong because the evolution
as used in quantum mechanics where you
say evolve according to the schrodinger
equation
and then you don't say that the
schrodinger equation
describes reality you say make a
measurement
and it tells you the problem is well
what's making a measurement when you
wheel in
on the cupboard this machine which makes
a measurement
that machine is made out of the same
things as everything else
so why doesn't it evolve according to
the throning equation
it doesn't make a measurement it would
say doesn't say i see this or this or
this
i see a particle here or particle here
or a particle here i see
this super position if possible here
positive here is particle here and it
might have a dial on it which says
particle here superposed with seeing
down by that particular supervisory
seeing particle here right but you don't
see that you see any one of them
so that isn't the way the world works
the world does not evolve
according to the schrodinger equation it
evolves according to
this curious mixture of schrodinger
evolution
collapsible wave function schrodinger
evolution collapse of the wave function
i mean that's what quantum mechanics
when anybody uses quantum mechanics
that's what they do they use this
of course and they say well i'm not
clever enough to understand how quantum
mechanics explains this
i'm just working here well none of us
are quite quantum
clever
and basically just say we just use it as
an algorithm for making predictions and
we're not actually describing
the world but but you use the language
inconsistent and that was the point i
wanted to pick up on
yes because other people use more polite
languages say
perhaps it's incomplete and
and and so why do you say inconsistent
as opposed to we still
need to go further i think because
people who say incomplete
nobody listens to them so i'm trying to
be a little ruder
no i don't know i it is inconsistent
because
i mean i think they're just polite you
see incomplete
i guess probably well another way to say
anything do you say newton's theory
is wrong or incomplete i say it's
you know it's it's it's the right theory
in a limited domain of reality and then
you go outside that domain
and it fails and you have to extend your
theory and and so forth
but what i mean a little bit differently
is here so let's go back to quantum
mechanics
yeah there are approaches for instance
the boom de bruy approach to quantum
mechanics
that gives an answer to the quantum
measurement problem it's a
self-contained theory it's
non-relativistic although some people
say you can relativize let's put that to
the side
wouldn't that be a consistent version
of quantum mechanics or would you
perhaps not call that quantum mechanics
any longer
well um i
i had long talks with bob when i was at
back up back college because we were
he and the bezel highly yes
i we we and the various other people we
used to have weekly meetings we had lots
of long discussions
so so i didn't know about his point of
view but it was hard to pin him down
i always thought he was very much like a
like a wave function himself
he he was talk about something and he
sort of spread out over the universe
like a wave
and you pick your question you ask him a
question you see and
it would collapse on this and give you a
very precise answer to your question and
then it would start to spread out and
spread out over the universe again like
this
so i thought he was very much in his
arguments very much like a wave function
which would collapse from time to time
but but yes i know there are there are
all sorts of models like that and the
drw theory which has spontaneous
collapse
sure and i i'm a great respect of all
these
i i have great respect for all these
theories i think they're
i i certainly would say go with it do it
but i think you see the thing i've been
i've taken advantage of
of of the lockdown
to do something which i never really
worked on which is to develop
the few ideas that had on collapse of
the wave function
to see what more you can say about it
yeah and the thing is
i certainly think it's a gravitational
effect i think that's yeah
right strong argument for that which has
depend i mean it's a very
limited argument but it's fairly string
and it's strong in its limited context
it says
you see the fundamental principle behind
einstein's general theory of relativity
is the principle equivalent it says the
gravitational field at least instead of
locally
yeah is equivalent to a free-fall
i mean galileo you imagine him dropping
a big rock and a small rock
even if he didn't actually do it he
certainly thought about it
and there's an insect on one looking at
the other would not experience
any now this means there are two ways
you could look
an experiment say you're doing a
tabletop experiment
quantum experiment and you want to take
into consideration the earth's
gravitational field
one way is to put into the hamiltonian
quantum jargon but whatever you do it's
a procedure you put in the potential for
the gravitational field just as though
it was any other quantum
field and go ahead fine the other way of
doing it is say no no that's wrong
you should imagine your coordinate
system's dropping freely
and there's no gravitational field you
do it that way you get
almost the same answer why almost
well there's this the expression is
exactly the same
except for what's called a phase factor
this is just a multiple
wave function you multiply by this thing
which is called the phase factor
now that phase factor you say when you
make a measurement you could use squares
and it doesn't make a difference
but you look at it carefully and you see
it's got in it
the term involving the cube of the time
an exponential of the cube of the time
which means
that you're you have what's called a
different quantum vacuum
see in quantum field theory you have
different kinds of vacuum
and you have to settle on which vacuum
you're using
to make sense of your theory but you
should be consistent with your vacuum
in order to have a system quantum field
here now here
you have a different vacuum depending on
which viewpoint you're taking well that
could be fine stick to your vacuum and
you're okay
that's okay unless you have say a big
say uh baseball sitting on the table
and you're trying to put that into a
superposition of being here and here
that's now making it a quantum object
now
you have to consider the gravitational
field of the baseball
and you where now you're in trouble
because if you use the
old you say look let's say the newtonian
view which means
putting a term in the hamiltonian that's
fine you've got no problem
but if you say that's not the right
outlook you should use the einstein in
perspective
then you have this vacuum which is
changing all the time and you've got
superpositions of different ones
then you're in trouble how do you
estimate the trouble
well you can make a measure of what's
wrong and it's a it's a kind of
uncertainty in the in the system and you
take an integral of that over the whole
system
and you see that uncertainty is a is an
uncertainty in the energy of the system
and then you use the heisender
heisenberg time energy and certainly
relationships i guess
which says it gives you a lifetime so
that's a lifetime of the system
and that is a prediction it says that if
you have a system with a superposed
baseball it can only remain in that
superposition for a certain length of
time
for a baseball it would be ridiculously
tiny fraction of a second
right so you have to have smaller things
to get it bigger and bigger
so that you could preserve this quantum
state for long enough
to see the collapse so you're saying
that the linearity of quantum mechanics
gets spoiled by gravitational influences
that's the
perspective what i'm saying is it's you
want to be more even-handed lots of
people talk about quantizing gravity
and that's what you're supposed to do
the singularities but you see that's
very far from what we can have to look
at physics at 10 to the minus 33
centimeters or something
that's very hugely far from any
measurement but what about the other way
around
not the effect of quantum mechanics on
gravity but the effects of gravity on
quantum mechanics
now that is much more within the scale
of things we might
be able to measure right and there is an
experiment
which has been going on for goodness
knows i don't know a couple of decades
by now i think
by dirk barmister and colleagues of his
which he's getting pretty close to the
stage of
actually performing it he
i think maybe by in within the next year
or two
he might well see something there are
other experiments i have a colleague
yvette fuentes
who who has a plan for doing doing
experiments with
those einstein condensates and there are
other things people have in mind
i think that's a big important area to
try and do experiments to test to see
whether you can actually without
you know bringing in an observer or
something like that
in a con self-contained physical system
see a collapse of the wave function yeah
via gravitational influence
gravitational effect yes right
is this is this why for instance you're
not a fan of
string theory's attempt to give a
quantum theory of gravity or
is that a broader set of i think the the
trouble i have with that is more than
the dimensionality the extra
dimensionality
you see i think that why does that
bother you you're this maverick thinker
who has all these wild ideas
yeah the possibility of more dimensions
goes all the way back to klutz and klein
you know in the early part of the 20th
century
well look you see i i have my public and
my private reason to object
okay and i'm now i'm i'm public i'm not
slightly public yeah yeah really just us
and a few friends really
listening oh yeah just a few friends
well the public reason was always
to do with the arguments i've just been
giving you
that there is a trouble with gravity
that that
i mean you can't the theories don't
don't really coexist properly
and that
no i have a public reason which is
that's one of the public reasons
the other one was more to do with the
the problems of the extra dimensions as
you were saying
yeah um i mean
this tiny i mean you're trying to get
rid of them by making them very very
small
but the trouble is when you're making
them very small you you
you um um have problems with stability
the quantums
i mean i don't and i did argue i i think
don't want to go into this i haven't
really
thought about these arguments for a long
time i don't i haven't seen anybody
contradict them
i have written a couple of papers on
that why you why you would expect
and in books too why we would expect
these
um tiny little knots or whatever they
are of
extra dimensions tied up into the knots
why they would be unstable and and you
would you they would
decay and stuff like that i mean there
are arguments a lot of them invoke
issues of
supersymmetry which again you can
question and then
imagine breaking and the effects of but
um
yeah i mean i i certainly appreciate the
concern
i guess my view is that um there are
issues worth thinking about
but by no means would it be enough to i
think i never could
i think the trouble i had the strength
let me put it in a different way the
trouble have a string theory
is that it's really pretty in a blunt
way it's being done by mathematicians
now you see i might be
calling a mathematician i hope i am but
it's
i mean what this great strength of
string theory and
and what's done is amazing things it has
done in mathematics
and i agree it has done amazing things
in mathematics
let me take edward whitten and and
followers of him and
sure there have been they've
made big inroads revolutions in
different areas of mathematics
that's completely true but when it comes
to physics
i think you have to apply different
criteria
and i think the exciting theory is to
develop for that reason
and i have nothing against that at all
but to make them into physics is a huge
stretch
for a squash i've put a lot of stretches
the other way around you've got to
squash
all this and you've got you don't see
any evidence for the super symmetry
you've got problems with that you've got
problems with the
making the higher dimensions stable um
[Music]
i could never quite see even with the uh
with the
super symmetry you you have them stable
but still right
i really don't want to go into that too
much that's okay i guess i would just
and then i do want to move on to one
final thing if you uh grant us a few
more minutes
i would say that for for for me just
from my perspective the fact that
you could extract general relativity
from
string theory a quantum mechanical
description of vibrating filaments
and you can pull einstein's ideas out of
it if the history of science had
gone in a different order we would have
had string theory before the general
theory of relativity and then with these
extra dimensions the ability
when appropriately thinking about them
to embrace all of the successes of the
past
symmetry breaking family structure of
particles discrete symmetries may be
tied up with the geometrical form of the
extra dimensions
it just strikes me that there's a lot of
successes of the past that so naturally
fit within
string theory which puts gravity and
quantum mechanics together at least
on paper in a consistent way but i get
your point i mean
it is not yet connected to observable
physics
that we can test and who knows when that
will happen so that's
that's definitely um i think
an aesthetic quality which is somewhat
different
you see i think there is an aesthetic
which is important in mathematics which
is not quite the same
as the aesthetic in physics i think in a
way it's been the mathematical one which
has been driving the strings
now you see i'm a great admirer of
mathematical aesthetics and and what you
can do with it and i think it's
tremendous yeah i don't think it's
spilled over into the physics i think
that the physics
it's a different thing and i i think
i think we could go on all night yeah no
i agree but i can certainly see that
that's a that's a valid point but i
wanted to um
to turn to now a final topic if you
would
are some of the ideas you've been
developed to helping unconsciousness on
on
what it is that's happening inside of
our heads you know there's this deep
hard problem of consciousness how is it
that we have
qualia sensations of colors emotions
thoughts understandings and
my my take on your position is that you
are you are straight down the line
physicalist you are not imagining a
duelist picture of the world is that
correct
yeah that's certainly the way i view
myself i mean
differently but and and so so then the
challenge is
to understand what's happening up here
in the language of physics or the
language of physics that we've yet to
fully articulate so one question along
those lines is
many people use the metaphor of a
computer as the model
of of thought processes inside the head
and you have
come out with an argument that you feel
that that is a completely misguided
metaphor that what we do inside of our
heads is not
likened to the algorithmic approach say
of a
conventional computer i think we have to
be a little careful
because there are different parts of our
heads yes for sure for sure i think
understanding you know the quality of
human understanding i mean if we talk
about cerebellum i'm quite
prepared to believe that that may be a
computer analogy it might work very well
well as we know it's completely
unconscious and
of course we don't understand how that
works either but um
the arguments as you say understanding
no this goes back again to my
graduate student days when i was in
cambridge
and i went to cambridge uh let's do pure
mathematics algebraic geometry i sort of
even that i was doing all slightly
off-beat kind of theory
but i decided i would like to go to
other lectures
on other topics and i went to a
wonderful course by herman bondi
on general relativity which was a great
course
i worked to a course by
a mathematician called steen a logician
where i learned about computing machines
i learned about
uh touring machines i knew what they
were i learned about
girdle's theorem now i'd previously been
worrying
with a colleague of mine when i was an
undergraduate ian percival we had
lots of discussions about these things
and i was really troubled by the idea
that girdle's theorem seemed to prove
that there were things in mathematics
that were true and you couldn't prove
okay now i learn about girdle's theorem
in steen's lecture
and the way i learned it he made the
it made it very clear what it was that
you have a set of procedures
of proof now if you accept these
procedures of proof
and that if they come up with feed in
the theorem
chug chug chug chug if it comes up and
says yes
it's true then by examining the methods
of proof
in the procedures you look at the the
axioms and the
uh well you defined it up into maxims
and metal
never mind all that stuff as long as you
believe you look at the first one and
say okay yeah that's okay
anything you get from that must be
tracked that's true that's all right
that's all right
not sure about that ah it's okay i see
why that works you go through all that
anything that if it comes up with yes
it's true
then you believe it's true
girdle produces a statement which your
belief
in its truth is actually outside
your understanding that it's true i mean
it's amazing i
i just thought that's absolutely
stunning you show this thing is true
but cannot be proved by means of those
proof methods you prove it by means of
your belief
in the trustability of those truths but
your trust
your understanding of those
proof procedures that goes beyond the
following of the truth procedures
now what does it mean by understanding
it well something about your conscious
goings-on and i thought that i had the
view that it's got to be something
non-computational in and it's not a
turing machine of course it might be a
turing machine which
is so complicated that we could never
understand it
but then the argument you've got went
through all complicated things mainly in
my book shadows of the mind which
followed the emperors of mind but really
the argument is much simpler than that
you say well it's it's nice to pick on a
nice
on a a theorem which i didn't know
at the time which is typical good
stein's theorem it's a really lovely
theorem
it's proved in 1945 where you take any
integer
and you write it in the binary form
which means sums of distinct powers of
two
and then you look at the exponents and
you see those are numbers which are not
written that way so you write those as
extended powers of two and then you look
at the index and you go on and this
chain comes to a limit
and then you have two procedures you
take you look at that number
and you replace all the no you you place
replace all the twos by threes
the numbers got hugely larger then you
subtract one
so please hold the threes by fours
subtract one
fours by fives subtract one good stein's
theorem
says that this procedure always ends
with zero now some of them lectures with
that you say okay try it with three you
just
comes down try with four i would not
recommend using your laptop
programming it into that i would not
recommend using your mainframe
i would not recommend using any computer
known on the planet
take out a piece of pad of paper and a
pencil
and work it out yourself you can see why
it comes
it's it's tricky if it was four you can
see what comes down it's a little
trickier to see why for any
number it comes down it depends on
something called transfinite
induction what about this is not that
the point about this is how do we know
it's true
how did evolution produce in this
algorithm
in our heads by natural selection
something which is so complicated
from the experiences of our ancestors
you know
killing sabretooth tigers or whatever
they were doing
domesticating animals growing crops
um that's nothing to do with this kind
of stuff
what we've developed is this general
concept
procedure whatever it is of conscious
understanding
so my argument was that it cannot be the
production
of some very complicated algorithm
because natural selection could never
have
come across something that we can see
it's true by
um simple reasoning let me try it before
i don't have to go to the
transfiner thing
so um okay
so then i thought i'm i didn't know
about good signs at that time but i knew
about
the girls theorem then i thought to
myself well there's something going in
our heads
which must be non-computable what kind
of physics can it be
well there's a continuum problem and do
you put thing on a computer
well i didn't think that was probably it
you could get good approximations that
that's a point which you have to worry
about is but let's i didn't
settle on that i just thought it's not
that's not the problem
well what about newtonian dynamics well
you could put that in the computer
what about general relativity yeah well
now we even know because with
calculations and ligo and all that stuff
sure you can put that on a computer
hard to do but still computational
calculations
what about quantum mechanics then i
thought about dirac's first lecture
what did he do he took out a piece of
chalk he was talking about first of all
particles and he said well an electron
could be here and it could be here
and in quantum mechanics it can be here
and in here at the same time you're
going to the superposition of this state
and that state and that's
a quantum state can involve civil
positions
what about a piece of chalk and he took
out a piece of chalk put it here and
here and i think he
then broke it in two now the trouble is
when i say i think
my mind wandered and i think i was
looking out of the window and think
about something else i have no idea what
when my concentration came back to the
lecture he'd gone on to the next thing
i vaguely remembered in mentioning
something about energy
but i had no idea what it was that
resolved this problem
so i was left with this puzzle of the
red collapse of the wave function and so
i thought well
that must be it that must be where there
is something non-computational going in
so i eventually well i thought i
eventually would write a book about it
and i had this idea
that i would write the became the
emperor's new mind
around about the same time stephen
hawking was writing his brief
history of time i remember
yes he he got um
um really got to write the forward
see that actually that time not many
people knew about him and i kept
wondering you know he
is this this great physicist a great
thinker and nobody seems to have
known anyone i i remember wheeling
around in his wheelchair and thinking
that
yeah and uh at that time he wasn't very
well known but then
after the briefing yes it was
you just told him his name yes um
what's his name the one who wrote before
never mind
uh i'm not sure actually
uh yep he was a well-known expositor of
science in the us
um are you saying he brought the forward
to hawkins a brief history of time well
yes
so i thought well i've got that i don't
even know who that was all the time
someone in the chat will no doubt
uh tell us
i thought well i need somebody to write
it so i thought of martin gardner
yeah all right so i sent my book to
martin gardner
i'm not sure i'd finished it at that
point i wrote to him and i would not be
nervous about what he thought he said no
i agree with you
right he was very happy to write her so
i thought then
okay well at least the book probably
won't disappear without trace
right but uh it probably is more than
that absolutely did more than that of
course but but
but but if you're hanging your hat on
incomputability being in the measurement
problem
does it disturb you that there are
proposed solutions to the measurement
problem that are computable
like we were talking about before you
know the boom
correct you see that's all yeah you just
think they're wrong um
no no i think they were wrong right
that's right
no it's a great challenge how do you
make a measurable
how do you make a a theory that's
included which is non-computing
and you see there are there are are
there here's a little direct again you
see this is interesting
i don't know whether this is it's a nice
example and i think it could
be a representative the iraq didn't just
discover the equation of the electron
but he had a period of his life
where he studied classical
electrodynamics now why on earth was he
doing that
i don't really know but he was looking
at classical particles
and how do they and he ran into this
equation because he was looking at the
self
the self acceleration problems you you
have to look at
sure and then he got to these uh
self-accelerating particles or
exponential behavior
and so you have to ha you now have a
third order equation
it's got too many parameters because
you've got all these
runaway solutions yes but how do you get
rid of the runaway solutions
well you've got to look to see
eventually is it going to run away it's
like a tiering machine you've got to
know
is that turing machine ever going to
stop or not
i think it's probably a non-computable
problem see you think it's
non-computable to determine whether
you'll have a runaway i see you're
saying that it may be a long time in the
future that the electron just takes off
or or something of that i mean i don't
know
i don't have a problem but it's at least
it's a candidate
right because it's it's looking to the
ultimate future you're saying
is this this solution is to be richard
this solution is to be discarded if at
any point
it runs away and the runaway is is
that it goes on computing and and the
space goes out to infinity
gotcha something like that i mean i
don't know whether it's not
but i think it's it's an interesting
candidate so one final question
that's related to this do you think that
girdle's incompleteness theorem
tells us something specific about the
ultimate physical laws
yeah what do you what do you think it
tells us well i do
i wouldn't have said that necessarily
you say only because because it contains
the
physical world contains conscious beings
you see and so i argue that conscious
beings
fair enough when i wrote the book i
tried to reign
to learn up about neurophysiology and i
did learn a sign of that about the
hodgkin uh nerve propagation and all
that stuff and then i thought
that's not going to have a hope you see
how can you preserve quantum coherence
in nerve propagation
when it you know you've got these
electric fields
propagating right into the brain it
seemed to be hopeless
and so at the end of the book i just did
a follow the fuddled argument which i
didn't really believe
and that was it a bit of a denumber you
know
i didn't know but then
read my book and he wrote to me i get
lots of letters from people who for
a little bit you know crazy theories
from time to time
and i thought here's another one you see
and he talks about these microtubules
what are they you see
but then he's got pictures of them
somewhere they must be real so i look
them up and i think gosh they are real
now they're much more promising not just
because they're smaller
they're tubes and and well i didn't even
know
the difference between a and b lattices
but the a-lattice microtubules
are extremely symmetrical and i think i
was aware of the fact there's a thing
called the yantella effect
that if you have symmetrical molecules
and things like that
then you can have a ground level in the
quantum system which is
shielded which is degenerate so you can
have information in the ground level
which is shielded from excited levels so
there's a much better chance
in these little little tiny tubes
which are uh whether in the wall pretty
well all cells not quite also but in
most cells but most of them are b
lattice where the symmetry is not so big
so you've got to look for highly
symmetrical cells
i don't mean cells highly symmetrical
structures ins within the cells
which might preserve some kind of
quantum here well it's very speculative
i
don't i'm not saying it's anything less
than speculative but all these
discussions
of consciousness but even if it's even
if you were right or
or it's a stepping stone to be right do
you agree that this approach would still
leave open the mystery of why we have
inner sensations
at all i mean that hard problem of
consciousness is still
it seems to stand beyond any of the
ideas we're talking about do you agree
with that
um i think things are mysteries when you
don't
you see people used to worry about load
stones didn't they and
there were some mystical fields right
and they're still mysterious you don't
see them
but you understand them because you've
got a beautiful theory of them and you
can
make them do things for you like radio
waves and you can write
you've got maxwell's equations to do it
and then you've got quantum
electrodynamics which
make you do things which transistors and
goodness knows what which
sure and do we i mean is there does it
remove the mystery just because you have
a
theory which describes them i don't
think it does someone say that's an
unfair analogy to draw though because
all of those examples
are third-party available phenomenon
objective qualities of the world and let
me get to conscious experience
it's the one thing that's only available
subjectively so it stands outside all
those analogies
i don't think it is only available
subjectively and here we go back to
stuart hammeroff
i mean what does he do what's his day
job on that job i'm not sure whether
it's day or night he puts people to
sleep on certain quotes because he says
it's different from sleep
he puts people under general
anaesthetics and he's
extremely interested in what this
actually doing what kind of substances
do it it's not a chemical effect because
the different
materials which put you to sleep
are not chemically related right it's
some physical process
or something okay
i mean uh i that it means you can probe
consciousness
well you see not just you can't probe it
uh so i mean
you know even you know psychedelics
right we can probe it in many many
different ways
that's true i can't get inside your head
and you can't get inside my head
by getting inside it you see i don't
know i mean or you don't have
wires attached to one person's head and
so you can just yeah what else is
thinking
you might have someday right yeah at
that point maybe one would think of it
as an objective uh
quality and the analogy might i mean i
could see the the
trouble you have of thinking of things
as internal in some sense
right
well i'm i'm not stopping it stopping
making trying to make theories about it
so i mean i can see why people think
it's some
you could see it's an excuse for not
worrying about the problem and i think
that's in quantum mechanics if you look
back at
uh what the old people
when they were young in those days you
used to think about quantum mechanics
we'll call them yes absolutely and a lot
of them thought
that it was the conscious perception
yeah which reduces the con
the quantum state yeah vigner yeah yeah
i know i talked to vigner about these
things
yeah for norman did you think that it
was nutty when you heard about
when he would say things like that no i
didn't think it was nutty
i didn't um no he actually he was fairly
broad-minded
about these things he thought this was
one point of view so i think
i never thought i don't think
i like all these things you i think
you've got to have a stage in your life
where you believe some of these things
um so there was a stage in my life where
i thought you know i thought many worlds
made sense
things like that yeah i i went through
that period too
yes i had stayed in my life when i
thought string theory was a wonderful
idea
actually i'm still in that idea yeah no
i still do it
i i like the strings i never have
anything against the strings it's just
good
when the dimensions went up too high
that's what worried me right
so i mentioned that that was the final
question but if you don't mind i do have
one final point that i'd like to just
end
there's been a lot of interesting work
lately the information
paradox in in black holes
where everything is heading toward i
think a communal belief at least among
the string theorists and
many quantum gravity people that
information is not lost in black hole
evaporation stuff falls in it evaporates
and you could in principle recover the
information
that fell in you're not of that
perspective
right absolutely not yes
there's a question about how much of it
is in the radiation yes i mean i guess i
used to think most of it was destroyed
in the singularity but i think uh
don page was arguing that it's about 50
50. 50 50 right
i could it doesn't make much matter when
it comes to the hawking points
there's all those squizzles through
those points anyway so don't
make much difference no but there has to
be a non-unitary behavior there
in the uh no well 50 well
50 50 is is is pretty bad isn't it but
now but now the page curve
the arguments right that are inspired by
string theory but right within
the structure of gravity general
relativity that you can understand the
page curve you can understand the
entanglement it all seems to be holding
together
in a way that's unitary yes but look
you've got a single think of the
conformal diagram you've got a
singularity here
you've got ports out here you've got
information
which you've got particles which get
destroyed on the singularity you've got
its partner
said an epr partner which goes out the
other side right
now one of the victims of quantum
mechanics is you you can't
copy information sure sure no cloning
here
we're saying no cloning here now if
you're saying this information
is retrieved in the exterior well it's
copying what's what's going on in the
singularity yeah i mean the arguments
that some are putting forward you know
susquehanna mel de santa
others that in some sense the outside
and the inside really shouldn't be
thought of as distinct
and they're really describing in some
sense the same state as opposed to a
copy of a state but uh maybe that will
take us too far afield to
uh to film the depths of those arguments
you're quite right i don't believe it
right that that's certainly uh the point
i wanted to get to
in some sense i've slightly shifted my
view on that so
because my view usually was
okay quantum gravity whatever it is
you're applying quantitative describes
theory it's it's
not the right theory it's got to involve
the collapse of the wave function
so any argument which which and i still
believe this argument any arguments
which depends on unitarity
at this level where you've got a hugely
early it's it's missing a part of the
story
you know he was sitting on the monstrous
part of the story
not just the tiddly powers maybe most
gravity phenomena you see i'm missing a
little tiny about but no this is the
main
picture i totally understand so so that
you've got to find a very gravitational
gravitized quantum mechanics you can't
use
arguments from unitarity that's just
yeah
that would be my normal argument against
this i mean certainly
you don't want any firewall or anything
i don't know what what's the current
view on star wars
well that's an interesting question so i
think the current view
on firewalls is that um
from a certain perspective it would be
as if there's
a firewall because in some sense
the gathering up of the external
information
changes the system in such a way that
generates the firewall so it's not
abstractly that it's there but it's the
act of acquiring the information
that causes the firewall to exist at
least i asked this very question last
week to juan mauldin who gave a
colloquium at columbia
on the latest thing and that was the
answer at least that i understood that
he
gave i've not investigated it fully
enough on my own
and and drove to if you took a spaceship
towards the
galactic center yeah would you encounter
a firewall i don't i don't know the
i don't know how these new ideas impact
the uh you might see it too
in event horizon telescope there's no
yeah right
exactly exactly so these uh these things
are not just abstract
anymore but anyway it's been a it's been
a great conversation
uh roger penders thank you so much for
spending the time
covered we covered quite a lot of ground
you know from the the early aha moments
through ideas of black holes in the 60s
through cosmological ideas through
quantum mechanics measurement
consciousness you've sort of covered it
all which is great so thank you so much
without mentioning twisted theory except
yeah we haven't done twister theory yeah
so that'll be our next conversation
uh so we'll launch that at some point
enjoy
enjoy the ceremony next week uh which
which is uh you know well deserved honor
winning the
2020 nobel prize in physics and uh you
know much success with all these
wonderful ideas
going forward you know i'm just excited
to see where where it all
lands out so again thank you for joining
us
and uh and congratulations again thank
you very much
indeed thank you all right everyone so
we've uh
we've been at it for two and a half
hours now i think unfortunately i'm not
gonna do much
more because um i uh i desperately
need to use the facilities i can't um
sit this long as i used to but uh
i hope you enjoyed the conversation with
uh roger penrose
a lot of wild ideas uh uh
really and the amazing thing is that
it's not just ideas in a vacuum these
are ideas now that
have at least some of them been tested
through the observation of black holes
so in any event we will continue to have
these sessions
on a semi-regular basis as i mentioned
before happy to hear your suggestions
many of you do
suggest that we have a conversation with
roger penrose which i'm glad that we
have done
and uh i'm looking forward to our
getting together sometime soon again
sign up for the world science festival
newsletter follow world science festival
on youtube if you want to follow me on
twitter i always announce these events
there
too that we're having i'm at be green on
twitter
i don't even know what my handle is on
facebook i don't use it that much
anymore i probably should
and my son tells me i should start using
instagram so for those of you in the
younger side of things
instagram at some point soon i will
start using that as well
again thanks for joining us looking
forward to our next session
look out for the announcement of when
that will be
okay brian greene signing off
you